BY MAKING US SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING SENATE
HERE SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC. HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC. AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIRES
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN A COUPLE OF TIMES
IT'S BEFORE US RIGHT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN FOUR NINE
SEVEN NINE EIGHT SEVEN. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY WILL OPEN YOUR
LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY FEEDBACK YOU MUST ACTUALLY
MUTE THE DEVICE THAT YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE.
MAYBE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE. OUT TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LATIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO NEW
ONLINE TOOLS. SO PLEASE BE
PATIENT AND NOT WE WILL SEEK TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD. AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
OUR COURT REPORTER I'M GOING TO
ASK ALL SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES
AND WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY.
OCCASIONALLY I MAY INTERRUPT
YOU IF FOR SOME REASON WE HAVE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES OR- WE
CAN'T HEAR YOU SO PLEASE
FORGIVE ME IN ADVANCE I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
TESTIMONY IS CAPTURED AND- THAT
ARE COURT REPORTERS ABLE TO GET
IT DOWN ACCURATELY THAT.
INCLUDES IF YOU MAY BE SPEAKING
TOO FAST. SO THAT SHE'S NOT
ABLE TO CAPTURE YOUR- YOUR
COMMENTS SO AGAIN WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I AS- WE
BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA. WE NEED
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND SO A
REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES.
YOU'LL NEED TO TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE FOR THE ROLL CALL
AND EVERY TIME WE THOSE SO WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ROOF
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER HERE LEHRER
HERE THEY'RE HERE BATES BATES
AT HERE ATKINS THANK YOU AND
FOR THE- MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND PEOPLE OBSERVING TODAY LET
ME JUST AGAIN POINT OUT THAT WE
HAVE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES
HAPPENING AS- AS WE ARE MEETING
TODAY AND SO I HAVE A NUMBER OF
COLLEAGUES SENATORS GROVE AND
CALM LOGGER WHO SERVE ON BUDGET
SUB- CENTER LAYERED I THINK
YOU'RE NOT HAVING ONE TODAY SO
WE'VE WE'VE GOT YOU THE ENTIRE
TIME- SO WHAT WAS MY POINT. TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES MOVING IN AND OUT
BECAUSE OF THAT AND SO I WANNA
MAKE SURE YOU KNOW IT IS
BECAUSE WE ARE DOING DOUBLE
DUTY- MADAM VICE CHAIR WILL
TAKE OVER AT SOME POINT BECAUSE
I WILL HAVE TO LEAVE- BUT WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO GET AS MUCH
BUSINESS DONE AS POSSIBLE TODAY
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT HEARING-
BUT FOR THE RECORD I WANTED
PEOPLE TO KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE SOME COMINGS AND GOINGS-
AND THAT WOULD BE THE REASON
WHY. SO IF THERE ARE NO
OBJECTIONS I WANT TO TAKE UP-
FIRST ON TODAY'S AGENDA
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR IN THAT
WOULD BE ITEMS TO F. AND G. N.
TWO F. N. G. INCLUDE OF MEMBERS
OF THE STATE. BOARD OF TRUSTEES-
S. THAT WOULD BE. ITEM F.
MELANIE SHELBY. AN ITEM. MARC
TO. AGAIN TO THIS BOB BOARD OF.
SORRY I LEFT IT OUT THE BAR
BOARD OF TRUSTEES. WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION I WOULD MOVE
THE OF THE ITEMS YOU JUST
OUTLINED AND MAKING SURE DO I
NEED TO SEPARATE THOSE OUT I
CAN TAKE ITEM TO F. AND G.
TOGETHER. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR OF MOTION IS ON THE
FLOOR MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ROOF KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED. I BATES.
BATES I. AYE AT FIVE AND WE
WILL THAT. THE ROLL OVER ON THE
ACT- FOR MISS GROWTH TO ON WHEN
SHE- I WOULD ALSO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER THREE
WHICH IS BILL REFERRAL. SO OF.
THE YOU SENATOR COM LAGER-
MADAM SECRETARY FOR CALL THE-
GROW. KAMLAGER FIVE AM LONGER%
HIGH LAYER. LAYERED I BE. ALL
RIGHT BATES I CAN HI ATKINS.
AND WE WERE LEAVE THE BILL WERE
I NUMBER THREE OPEN SENATOR
GROWTH TO ADD ON WHEN SHE
ARRIVES. AND WITH THAT I WE NOW
MOVE TO GOVERN APPOINT WERE. TO
APPEAR. AN ITEM ONE A. IS THE
UP. OF I MS RAND OFF- AS CHAIR
OF THE AIR READ. BOARD WE ARE
THE ITEM FIRST. AS CHAIR OF
BOARD IN THEN WE WILL MOVE TO.
I BE C. D. AND E. WHICH ARE
OTHER MEMBER OF THE RE. BOARD
AND TAKE THEM UP AS A PANEL.
AND ARE WE WILL HAVE THE
CONVERSATION AND DISCUSSION
TODAY. A. N- HOLD THE VOTE OVER
ODD BECAUSE I ANTICIPATE WE-
WILL NOT HAVE- THE NUMBER OF
MEMBERS THAT CAN VOTE FULLY ON
THIS AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO CONDUCT OUR
BUSINESS. ON AND GET THOSE
VOTES DONE BUT WE WILL DO THE
DISCUSSION TODAY IF WE ARE ABLE
TO GET THROUGH THE ENTIRE.
DISCUSSION AND TAKE THE VOTE WE
WILL BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
YOU KNOW THAT AS WE GET TO
ITEMS B. C. D. AND E. IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT WE WILL TAKE UP
AS A PANEL AND NOT VOTE TODAY.
HAVING SAID THAT- I WANT TO
WELCOME CHAIR RANDOLPH. I
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE ALBEIT
VIRTUALLY A. N. ASK IF YOU
WOULD INTRODUCED. FEEL FREE TO
RECOGNIZE ANYONE THAT IS WITH
YOUR THAT. YOU WANT ARE
RECOGNIZED AND AFTER YOU. YOUR
COMMENTS WE WILL GO TO MAKE OF
THIS FOR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
AND WITH THAT LET ME SAY WELL
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR- AS GOT
AND WAY TODAY. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE CHAIR VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE CAN AND
I'M SO PLEASED BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY- I WANT TO PAY GOVERNORS.
FOR A NEED JUSTICE. AND
INTEREST NEEDED SUPPORT WORK. I
WANT TO TAKE MY- CHRIS KELLY
FOR UNWAVERING. FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEAR- MIGHT. US UNTIL.
SAT IN JACK MADE OF WHOM WERE
DESCRIBE THEMSELVES AS CHILDREN
BECAUSE ARE NOW COLLEGE AND
HIGH SCHOOL RESPECTIVELY. I'M
AND I WANT TAKE OF MY FOR
MEMBERS TO WISH YEAR- MY SISTER.
AND MY BROTHER MICHAEL WHO WERE
ALL. SHOW PROUD OF ME AND
TAUGHT ME SO MUCH. AND WOULD
HAVE LET. TO BE HERE TODAY. I'M
TRULY HUMBLED TO HONEST.
LEADING AGENCY PASS WITH
PROTECT THE- HEALTH KNOWING OF
HEALTH. AT THE STATE WE HAVE
MADE GREAT. IN TYLER A FOURTH
IN TYPE IN OUR COUNTY HEAVY IN
RECESSED BECAUSE THAT'S MY.
CLIMATE IMPACTS LIKE WILDFIRE
AND EXTREME HEAT I NEED TO DO
ALL OF THIS WITH THE GOAL OF
PROTECTING THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED.
HARBISON LARGE AND COMPLEX
AGENCY HEADED BY A BOARD THAT
BY DESIGN HAD THE IN VARIED
EXPERIENCE. THAT EXPERIENCE IS
CRITICAL TO OUR LEADERSHIP AT
THE AGENCY AND I AM HONORED TO
WORK WITH MY COLLEAGUES AS WE
COLLECTIVELY MAKE REALLY
DIFFICULT DECISION. OUR WORK
CATCHES ALL AREAS OF OUR
ECONOMY. WE HAVE COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS FEDERAL STATE
LOCAL AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
INDUSTRY UNIONS SCIENTISTS AND
MANY MANY OTHERS IT CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT AND ARE IMPACTED BY WHAT
WE DO. IN MY CAREER I HAVE
ALWAYS TRIED TO LISTEN AND
CONSIDER A VARIETY OF
VIEWPOINTS AND BE OPEN TO
FINDING PRACTICAL AND
ACTIONABLE SOLUTIONS. TO MY
MIND THIS ROLE IS ONE WHERE
THOSE VALUES MUST BE
FOUNDATIONAL. AS BOARD CHAIR I
MUST BE ADAPTIVE COLLABORATIVE
AND RECEPTIVE AS WE NAVIGATE
THE RIGHT PATHWAYS TO ACHIEVE
OUR MANDATE OF PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND TACKLING
CLIMATE CHANGE. IN MY MIND IN
THIS ROLE I CANNOT TELL YOU HOW
MUCH I HAVE LEARNED FROM MY
FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS. TRYING TO
OUR UNION CONVERSATIONS WITH
THOSE WHO INTERACT WITH CARP
AND FROM OUR STAFF. I PLEDGE TO
ALWAYS STAY IN LISTENING AND
LEARNING MODE AS WE WORK TO
FIND THE RIGHT SOLUTIONS. I AM
EAGER TO WORK WITH YOU AS WE
TACKLE THESE DAUNTING
CHALLENGES ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO ANSWERING
YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SENATOR LAYERED WOULD YOU
LIKE TO START THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT AND LET ME
JUST SAY QUICKLY IN THE
INTEREST OF FULL DISCLOSURE. OF
THAT THE CANDIDATE TO WAS
GENERAL COUNSEL AT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY FOR FOUR YEARS
WHEN I WAS THE SECRETARY AND I
WORKED HARD TO HIRE HER AND I
WORKED HARD TO NOT HAVE HER
LEAVE WHICH I THINK IS THE
RECOMMENDATION AND HIS
SECRETARY. EVERYONE HAD AN
ASSIGNMENT WHETHER YOUR DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR LEGISLATION OR
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS OR FOR GENERAL
COUNSEL AND IT WAS MY GOAL AS A
MANAGER TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
HAD A MAJOR PROJECT IT MIGHT
NOT BE DIRECTLY WITHIN THEIR
ASSIGNMENT AND SO MS RANDOLPH
WAS ASSIGNED TO THE WHOLE
ISSUE. OF THE KLAMATH BASIN IN
THE KLAMATH DAM REMOVAL AND
WORKING WITH FORK AND WORKING
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
WORKING WITH- OF THE STATE OF
OREGON AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR AND ACQUITTED HERSELF.
VERY WELL AND THERE WAS A
REASON THAT SHE WAS TAKEN
BEFORE MY TIME TO BE PUT ON THE
PC AND I JUST FELT LIKE IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
ARE AT THE BEGINNING BECAUSE
BASED ON THE FOUR YEARS I
WORKED WITH HER. BEFORE WE DO
EVERYTHING IN THIS HEARING I
COULD NOT RECOMMEND HER HIGHLY
ENOUGH. BUT I THINK THAT THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU A FEW
QUESTIONS AND THEN ONE IS THAT.
THE ORDER THERE WAS ONE OTHER
STATEMENT I WANTED TO MAKE FOR
THE BENEFIT OF MY COLLEAGUES
AND THERE IS OCCASION BEEN
CRITICISM OF THE AIR BOARD FOR
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE ALL
THESE POWERS AND IT'S LIKE
THEY'RE UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS.
I WAS IN THE LEGISLATURE WHEN
THEY WERE GIVEN THOSE FILES SO
THEY HAVE THOSE POWERS BECAUSE
A DIRECTLY ELECTED LEGISLATORS
AND GOVERNORS DID IT WITH AB
THIRTY TWO AND SAID WE SHOULD.
CHARGE ONE AGENCY WITH CLIMATE
BUT THE ONE THING IS AN ALL ASK
IT IN A LITTLE BIT TO IS IT IS
THE CHARGE OF AIR QUALITY BEING
IGNORED IN THE FACE OF ALL THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE ON
CLIMATE ALL ASKED THAT IN A
MINUTE BUT- I WANT TO START
WITH THE FACT THAT. R. WHAT IS
CENTRAL. TO THEIR BOARDS WORK
ON CLIMATE ISSUES IS THE
SCOPING PLAN. AND IT
PERIODICALLY AS DONNA REED ON
AND NOW. OKAY HANG ON SENATOR.
LET ME JUST SEE WHERE OKAY OKAY
OKAY GREAT AND SO NOW YOU'RE
ABOUT TO EMBARK ON THE SCOPING
PLAN PROCESS AND IT WILL
REALLY. ASK ALL THE QUESTIONS
OF HOW TO UPDATE OUR OF THE
ROLE OF THE- BOARDED THIS TO
DIFFERENT ISSUES TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT SOME OF THE CHANGES OF
CONCERN WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
APPROACH TO SCOPING PLAN BOTH
IS IN WHAT YOU THINK NEEDS TO
BE CONSIDERED AND HOW IT'S
GOING TO INCLUDE PEOPLE AND
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
THAT QUESTION I AM. AT IS GOING
TO BE PLAYED A HUGE
UNDERTAKING- IT'S THAT IT
REALLY ALLOWS US TO LOOK AT
WHAT IS OUR HALF TO TWENTY
THIRTY HOW ARE WE- ACHIEVING
OUR TWENTY THIRTY GOALS A 40%
REDUCTION IN GHG EMISSIONS BY
NINETEEN NINETY UP FROM
NINETEEN NINETY. BUT THEN ALSO
LOOKING AT- AT OUR PAST TO
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. AND IN UNDERTAKING
THE SCOPING PLAN THIS TIME
AROUND. WE HAVE A LOT OF. TOOLS
IN THE TOOLBOX THAT WE NEED TO
BE ANALYZING DETERMINE WHAT
STRATEGIES TO DEPLOY A TO GET
TO CARBON NEUTRALITY AND TO
MEET OUR TWENTY THIRTY CALL. SO
WE HAVE AND SB ONE HUNDRED AND
THE MANDATE TO HAVE 1100% THAT
RETAIL SALES OF ELECTRICITY. WE
HAVE THE- KEVIN- HEARING HIS
VEHICLE EXECUTIVE ORDER WHICH-
DIRECTS US TO. MOVE TOWARDS
HEARING MISSION VEHICLE IN THE
LATE EIGHTIES FACED BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE AND THE HEAVY DUTY
SPACE BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE. AND
IS REALLY MEANT TO TACKLE THE
CRITICAL ISSUE OF
TRANSPORTATION WHICH HAS
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY AND
CLIMATE IMPACTS- IT ALLOWS US
TO LOOK AT HOW EXISTING
PROGRAMS ARE PERFORMING LIKE
CAP AND TRADE AND THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD. IT ALLOWS
US TO LOOK AT NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS AND TO SEE HOW
THOSE IT INTO OUR CREDIT
STRATEGY. SO IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS AND INPUT
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. IT WILL
TAKE A LONG TIME IT'LL TAKE A
GOOD AND TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO REALLY DO THE WORK WE
NEED TO DO WE JUST FARMS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE SO WE WILL BEGIN
MEETING. WITH THEM TO GET THEIR
INPUT YOUR P. BEGINNING INITIAL
WORKSHOPS- WITH A COMMUNITY AND
OTHER STATE AGENCIES. AND WE
WILL BE CHARTING A PATH FORWARD
TO GAIN PUBLIC INPUT AND-
INTERACTION- IN DEVELOPING THE
PLAN THERE'S A LOT OF- ANALYSIS
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN- MODELING
AND SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS. AND WE%
ARE VERY EAGER AND OPEN TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH- COMMUNITIES
AND STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT THEIR
VIEWS AND THEIR ANALYSIS THAT
THEY'RE SEEING- AND THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT THE BEST
STRATEGY TO DEPLOY. SO I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO DOING
THIS WORK AS AS AS YOU
MENTIONED WITH THE KLAMATH
EXAMPLE- THIRD OF. GATHERING
TOGETHER A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS IT'S SOMETHING I
ENJOY DOING AND I'M REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO DISCUSS THE
PLAN PROCESS. GRADE TEN AND I
KNOW THAT. THAT SB SIX
SEVENTEEN WAS ALSO ENACTED- BY
FIGURES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN OR
IN THAT PERIOD AND IT REALLY
ARE DIRECTED TO LOOK AT COULD
ADD COMMUNITIES OR OR MORE
INDIVIDUAL LOOKS HOW WHEN
YOU'RE DOING THIS FROM THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL WE DON'T
COOPERATE THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THEY'RE MORE
COMMUNITY BASED- OF. ANALYSIS-
LOOKS- EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
PROCESS- AND THE COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION- TEAM WITHIN OUR
AGENCY HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BOTH
INFORMALLY ADOPTED EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN. COMMUNITIES BUT THEN
ALSO IN COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
LOOKING AT. POSING COULD BECOME
SIX SEVENTY COMMUNITIES OR
COMMUNITIES THAT WE HAVE BEENWORKING WITH THROUGH OUR AND
COMMUNITY AIRCRAFT PROGRAM AND
OTHER MONITORING WORK. AND SO
HE THE WORK IN THOSE SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITIES TO
DEVELOP LOCAL AIR QUALITY
MONITORING PLANNED OR COMMUNITY
EMISSION REDUCTION PLAN AT THE
KEY AS THE CASE MAY BE AT WITH
REGARD TO DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES. THAT'S GIVEN US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- LEARN IT TOO
AND WORKING THOSE COMMUNITIES-
DEVELOP A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
WORK WITH THEIR DISTRICTS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL
INDUSTRIES- AND TRY TO DEVELOP
STRATEGIES AROUND EMISSIONS
REDUCTION. AND SO WHAT THAT
ENABLES US TO DO IS- REACH OUT
TO THOSE COMMUNITIES AND- BUILD
ON THOSE EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS-
TO WORK ON THE SCOPING PLAN AND
TO- AND TO HAVE ROBUST
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT WITH
REGARD TO TACKLING SOME OF THE
ISSUES AND THE SCOPING PLAN- SO
WE HOPE TO BUILD ON THOSE.
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS THAT
HAVE DEVELOPED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS- AND REALLY GAIN
SOME ROBUST INPUT INTO THE
PLANNING PROCESS AND WHAT DO
YOU THINK IS THE ROLE OF. OF
NOW THAT THERE'S MORE OF A
COMMUNITY BASED LOOK AS PART OF
THE OVERALL PROCESS- WITH
REGARD TO INCORPORATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATES
SO- OBVIOUSLY SOME DO NOT FEEL
HEARD IT IN VARIOUS CAR
PROCESSES WILL THIS ENHANCE
THEIR ABILITY TO. TO HAVE
FEEDBACK WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING.
AT THE MORE COMMUNITY LEVEL. I
HARD BEEN. GROWING OVER THE
YEARS INTO AS ITS ABILITY TO
WORK WITH ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES BUT WE STILL
ABSOLUTELY HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO- CHAU D. JACK YOUR MAMA
JUSTICE ADVISORY COMMITTEE- IS
AT THE KEY PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION THAT PROCESS OF
MAKING SURE THAT- WE ARE GIVING
THEM THE RESOURCES THEY NEED.
TO ASSIST IN THIS- WE'RE
LOOKING AT OPTIONS AROUND
COMPETITION AND OTHER WAYS TO
MAKE SURE THAT- THEY'RE ABLE TO
FULLY- ADVISE US AND IN TERMS
OF THIS IS A VERY TIME
CONSUMING PROCESS- AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT- THAT THEY THEY
ALL HAVE A LOT OF OTHER WORK TO
DO AND THIS IS GOING TO BE- AT
AT- A LOT OF WORK FOR THEM AND
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT AND THAT WE AND-
AND THAT WE FOSTER AS MUCH
PARTICIPATION AND INTERACTION
AS POSSIBLE. SO I AM OPTIMISTIC
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO- FAILED
AT A GOOD PROCESS THIS TIME AND
I'M HOPING THAT- AT THE END OF
THE DAY EVEN IF WE DON'T AGREE
ON EVERYTHING THAT THEY DO FEEL
HEARD AND FEEL THAT THEY HAVE
FULLY- PARTICIPATED IN THE
PROCESS- AND SO THAT'LL BE
MICHAEL AND FOR THE SKIPPING
PLAN I SUSPECT OTHERS MAY WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THAT BUT I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE INTRODUCED IT
THAT WAY OF TWO MORE QUESTIONS
AND ONE IS. ARM IN IN MEETINGS
YESTERDAY THANK YOU FOR MEETING
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES THAT. WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM AND A BIT.
ARE THE K. AND TRADE PROGRAM
CAME UP AND IT WAS MENTIONED AT
WASH. THE STATE OF WASHINGTON
DECIDED TO CREATE ITS OWN CAP
AND TRADE. AND IN DOING THAT
THEY FELT LIKE THEY MADE
CHANGES TO WHAT CALIFORNIA DOES
BASED ON LEARNING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA. EXPERIENCE THEN.
THERE HAVE BEEN TWO
INTERESTINGLY THERE'S TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS OF LOOKING AT
THAT BECAUSE SOME. CRITICS SAY.
OF THE AIRBOARD WAS INFLEXIBLE
ABOUT MAKING THOSE CHANGES HERE
IN WASHINGTON POINTED THEM OUT
AND THEN CONVERSELY. THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE COIN IS THAT-
CALIFORNIA LEARNED AND WAS ABLE
TO ADVISE WASHINGTON AND HOW TO
INCORPORATE THOSE CHANGES AND
IMPROVE THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
HOW WOULD YOU. SORT OF SPEAK TO
THAT COMPARISON BETWEEN
WASHINGTON AND CALIFORNIA. I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT-
THE TAPESTRY PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA HAS EVOLVED OVER
TIME AND THE- AND THE- THAT
SORT OF STRATEGIES WE HAVE
DEPLOYED IN THE PROCESS NEEDS
TO BE- UNDER GOD HAVE. EVOLVED
OVER TIME- AND I THINK THAT'S
APPROPRIATE- I THINK THERE WAS-
THERE HAVE BEEN CHANGES TO- HOW
TO HANDLE AND- SO FOR EXCESS
ALLOWANCES THERE DID HE DIDN'T
AND HOW TO HANDLE VARIOUS
ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP-
KEEP INVOLVING- I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WASHINGTON
LEARNED PLACE TO CONSIDER-
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE CAN TURN
INTO THE BILL CAN A COMMUNITY
AIR PROTECTION ASPECT. INTO
THEIR PROGRAM FROM THE- BUT IT
IT'S- AND IT'S- PROPOSED AND I
THINK THAT THAT IS. A TESTER
TO- CALIFORNIA GROWING AND
LEARNING AND BEING ABLE TO-
SHARE AN IMPORTANT LESSONS
LEARNED WITH OTHER STATE GOOD
I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT I'M
HOPING THAT. THAT WE CONTINUED
TO ADAPT AND TAKE THOSE CHANGES
INTO ACCOUNT LASTLY THE
QUESTION THAT I SORT OF TEED UP
AT THE BEGINNING. OR DO YOU
THINK WITH ALL THE EMPHASIS ON
CLIMATE THE DEER BORDERS PAYING
ENOUGH ATTENTION TO AIR QUALITY
ISSUES WHICH WERE ESSENTIALLY
ITS ORIGINAL CHARGE WHEN IT GOT
OFF THE GROUND. YES I DO I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW HIGHER HAS
WORKED HARD TO ADDRESS- AIR
QUALITY ATTACKS OVER THE YEARS-
AND HAS HAS ALWAYS DONE SO IF
YOU CAN YOU TO DO SO AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
COMMENT- ARE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE CLEAN AIR ACT AND OUR OWN
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS. HAVE HAD
GOOD RESULTS AND HAVE BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE- AND WE CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS IMPACTS FROM OUR GROUND
BREAKING LOW NOT CONDITIONS
REQUIREMENTS THE OMNIBUS HEAVY
DUTY TRUCK RULE- FROM OUR-
INSPECTION AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING INSPECTION
AND NAY NATURAL. THAT IS
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY- TO OUR
EXTENSIVE WORK WITH THE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS IN DEVELOPING
STATE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN- AND
THE STRATEGIES NEEDED TO REACH-
CLEAN AIR ACT THE PAYMENT. TO
OUR WORK IN THE LIGHT DUTY
SPACE- GETTING- RIGHT NOW WE'RE
WE'RE WORKING ON A NEW VEHICLE
STANDARDS- AND ARE EXCITED THAT
THE BY NET MINISTRATION IS
POISED TO RETURN OUR CLEAN AIR
ACT WAIVER SO THAT WE CAN.
CONTINUE. TO LEAD IN THAT AREA-
AND I FORGET TO MENTION AREN'T
FOR WORK. WE HAVE. AN
IMPRESSIVE NEW LAB OPENING IN
RIVERSIDE THAT IS GOING TO HOW
ARE- CONTINUED- ANALYSIS AND
CERTIFICATION WORK IN OUR
TESTING THAT WE DO TO IDENTIFY
VEHICLES THAT ARE IN VIOLATION
OF OUR STANDARDS- YOU KNOW THE
VOLKSWAGEN SETTLEMENT WHEN IS
THAT- HIGHEST. PROFILE ONE OF
THOSE BUT WE HAVE MANY CASES
WHERE OUR INTEREST NETWORK HAVE
CAUGHT THE LEADERS RED HANDED-
AND- AND WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE- SETTLEMENT FOR THAT
BENEFIT THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND YOU KNOW I
REALIZE OUR CLIMATE WORK- IS. A
CALL AND I GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION RATE- BECAUSE SOME OF
THAT HAPPENED BY AND ON THE
INTERNATIONAL STAGE AND THOSE
MEETINGS WITH WORLD LEADERS-
YOU KNOW MAKE CALIFORNIA PROUD
CALIFORNIANS PROUD THAT THEIR-
STATE IS LEADING A LOT OF AGE-
SO I CAN UNDERSTAND HOW. SOME
FOLKS MIGHT FEEL THAT THAT
OVERSHADOWS. DAY WORK ON THINGS
LIKE REDUCING EMISSIONS ON
OCEAN GOING VESSELS AND- AND
REGULATING FERRIES- REGULATORY
pACTIONS RELATED TO OFF ROAD
EQUIPMENT- SO I FEEL LIKE IT'S
MY JOB AS CHAIR TO MAKE SURE
THAT. I TELL THAT AIR QUALITY
WORK AS MUCH AS I CAN- AND TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS KNOW WE
ARE WE REALLY ARE ON A DAY TO
DAY. YEAH WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO
CLEAN UP OUR AIR. AND ADOPT THE
RIGHT STANDARDS- DAY IN AND DAY
OUT AND ENFORCE THOSE STANDARDS
DAY IN AND DAY OUT. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
LETTING ME ASK THIS QUESTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED HOT
MINIMIZE CHAIR- LET ME GO TO
YOU NEXT SO WE GIVE OUR OTHER
COLLEAGUE TOM TO CATCH HER
BREATH. AND LET THE RECORD
REFLECT THAT THE- SENATOR GROWS
WITH US. THANK YOU ARE A MAN
CHAIR AND- GET MY NOTES HERE
THE LAST PLACE. THIRTY SORRY I
LOST MY PLACE AND WE HAD A VERY
ON NICE CONVERSATION YESTERDAY
ON. RANDOLPH AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
TOOK THAT EXTRA TIME. TO DO OUR
VIRTUAL- WE WANT WISH THAT IT
WAS FACE TO FACE BUT I HAVEN'T
HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY WE COVERED
A NUMBER OF. ITEM OF. THAT I
THOUGHT WERE VERY IMPORTANT. TO
BRING FORWARD AND YOU ANSWERED-
YOU KNOW VERY THOUGHTFULLY AND
CERTAINLY- WITH ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR. THE IMPACT THAT WE MIGHT
HAVE. MORE IMPACT ON OUR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND I KNOW
THAT I SPECIFICALLY NOTED ONE
OF YOUR GOALS IS TO. SEEK A
BALANCE IN TERMS OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL NEED TO BE MADE ON THE OUR
CARGING STATIONS FOR EXAMPLE.
IN ENSURING THAT SO WE DON'T
PUT A GREATER BURDEN ON OUR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES THROUGH RATE
PAYING. TO FINANCE THOSE I
THINK ANOTHER ISSUE WE
DISCUSSED WITH A CLEARLY THE
COMPETITIVE ENOUGH. N MAKING
SURE THAT WE CAN STAY
COMPETITIVE- WITH OUR
INTERNATIONAL NEIGHBORS. AND
HOW THE REDUCTION OF. OUR THE-
THE REDUCTION IN FOSSIL FUEL
AND BASICALLY NO CARS PASSED BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE THAT ARE
PRODUCED- HOUSE FOSSIL FUEL.
ARE INDIAN ZERO THINK MYTHIC
AND IN TERMS OF- THE JOBS THE
GREEN JOBS. THAT ARE GOING TO
BE REPLACING OUR JOBS THAT ARE
IN THE OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
INDUSTRY I DO HAVE NUMBERS NOW
SO IT BECOMES EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT NOW AS- WE LOOK AT
WHAT CARBS CHALLENGES GOING TO
BE GOING IN THE- FUTURE I KNOW
AND- THEIR SUB. OF FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS JOB. IN THE-
OF. GREEN JABI IN KERN COUNTY
FOR EXAMPLE AND DOWN THE OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION INDUSTRY IS-
ON NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND ON HAS
AN AVERAGE SO THAT'S A 41%
REDUCTION. IN THE INCOME THAT'S
AVAILABLE FROM THAT KIND OF.
EMPLOYMENT FORTY FIFTH PUTTING
THOSE THINGS BACK ON ON. YOU
KNOW THE TABLE TO BE DISCUSSED
IF YOU GO FORWARD WITH THE
SCOPING PLAN AND NOW PROVIDING
NOT HIM PUT. UP FROM OUR PUBLIC
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT ARE VERY
VERY. ARE PROBLEMATIC IN TERMS
OF KEEPING OUR ECONOMY STRONG
AND CERTAINLY PROVIDING FOR THE
NEW WORKERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A VERY. WELL PAYING JOB.
IN WHAT WOULD BECOME REALLY THE
DOMINANT TE AND SO AS YOU TO
TAKE A CO LOOK THAT ISSUE
FORWARD- I HAVE A QUESTION.
THAT IS BECAUSE FROM ACCOUNTS.
THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT I
DIDN'T COVER YESTERDAY. BUT I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT ONE IF
YOU TAKE OVER THE CHAIR AND YOU
ARE REALLY. STRUCTURING A NEW
LEADERSHIP. AND THERE WAS A
CONCERN ABOUT THE- THERE WASN'T
A DELEGATION OF AUTHORITY
PASSED THE CHAIR TO BOARD
MEMBERS- IN MAKING SOME OF THE
DECISIONS ARE COMING FORTH WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS. SO I THE
QUESTION TO YOU IS WOULD YOU BE
MORE WILLING TO HAVE LET'S SAY
OUR TECHNICAL SUBCOMMITTEES
THAT NEED MORE LIKE WHAT GOES
ON OUT OF. OUR OTHER BOARDS.
CANCEL THAT IT'S NOT FULL
CENTRALIZED BUT IT'S MORE
COLLABORATIVE AND SHE LOOK AT.
THE ISSUES THAT COME BEFORE YOU
OFF CERTAINLY THAT FOR THE WAY
IT'S DONE MORE AT CPUC ARE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
SO IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU'D
BE TAKING A LOOK AT AND YOU SEE
THEY HAVE AN IMPORTANT CHANGE
THAT MIGHT BE NECESSARY AND I
THINK THAT THAT GOES TO THE
CREDIBILITY AND THE- CONFIDENCE
OF THE PUBLIC WHEN THEY
PROVIDED INPUT. THAT THERE'S
BEEN LEVELS OF ANALYSIS AND
DISCUSSION AT EACH LEVEL BEFORE
THAT'D THAT PARTICULAR
RECOMMENDATION. COMES FORWARD
TO THE BOARD PROPER. I'M SO I
GUESS I WOULD SAY A COUPLE
THINGS I THINK- HAS A MENTIONED
IN MY OPENING COMMENTS I THINK
AT TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE-
EXPERTISE OF MY FELLOW BOARD
MEMBERS REALLY IMPORTANT. AND
SINCE I'VE- BEEN HERE IT'S
BEEN- IT'S BEEN INTERESTING
HEARING FROM DIFFERENT BOARD
MEMBERS ABOUT ISSUES THAT
THEY'RE INVOLVED IN- FOR
INSTANCE YOU KNOW DOCTOR BOMB
HIDDEN IS INVOLVED AND THAT
QUITE A BIT IN THAT IN THE SIX
SEVENTEEN- PROCESS- VICE CHAIR
BURKE WAS VERY INVOLVED IN THE
CREAMFIELDS REWARDS HE ENTERED-
A BOARD MEMBER DALY TORY. VERY
INVOLVED IN- IN GETTING HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES OUT ON THE STREET
IN INTO- GARY MISSION HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES I SHOULD SAY- IN
LOS ANGELES AND REALLY VERY
ACTIVE IN THAT WORK- AND-
ADVOCATING FOR AND- YOU KNOW
FOR THE COURTS TO. RECOGNIZE
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES TO DEAL
WITH- WITH THE- THE VEHICLES
THAT ARE COMING IN AND OUT AT
THOSE. LOCATIONS SO I
ABSOLUTELY THINK IT'S- IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO RELY ON THE
EXPERTISE OF MY FELLOW BOARD
MEMBERS- TO THE EXTENT WE WANT
TO THINK ABOUT THE IDEA OF HAVE
TOO MANY YOU KNOW WE CAN
CERTAINLY LOOK AT THAT. ONE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OF COURSE
THE PC REYES THE AND THE FEES
THE PERSON SINCE AND HIGHER BE
IS THAT THAT THAT THOSE ARE
FULL TIME BOARDS AND WHO HAVE
SPECIFIC FULL TIME
RESPONSIBILITIES- BUT YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO LOOK AT WAYS
TO. INVOLVE THE BOARD MEMBERS.
HERE AT HIGHS IN DECISION
MAKING. THANK YOU I THINK A
GOOD VERY IMPORTANT ON FOR THE
PUBLIC HEAR THAT BECAUSE THAT
IS I USUALLY THE- CRITICISM
COMMON THAT WE- ARMS. WHEN I
WAS LOW THE LEVEL AND
ESPECIALLY ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN ORANGE COUNTY.
THAT THERE DIDN'T SEEM TO BE A
LOT OF THAT KIND OF INPUT
THROUGH A COMMITTEE STRUCTURE.
AND I AGAIN I HAVE BEING UP THE
CONFIDENCE OF THE PUBLIC ON A
LOT OF THINGS THAT. INITIALLY
WILL BE DIFFICULT AS WE GO
FORWARD AND I SPEAK I THINK WE
SPOKE ABOUT THE TIMELINES TO.
OUR TERROR RANDOLPH THAT
SOMEBODY ELSE MIGHT BE A
LITTLE- ENERGETIC. IN TERMS OF
TIME LINES AND THERE MIGHT BE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S KIND OF
WAITING OUT THERE PASSED TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE THAT CAN HELP A
LOT. R. AS WE MOVED TO THIS
NEW- ENERGY LEVEL BUT I.
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS. ABSOLUTELY YEAR YEAR
ON BACKGROUND AND YOUR RESUME.
OF ACT QUALIFIES YOU AS MY-
GOOD COLLEAGUE TO MY RIGHT TO
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WORKING FOR
HIM I'M SURE THAT. YOU GOT YOUR
MARCHING ORDERS MANY TIMES SO
I. LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR SIX F.
ABOUT CANNED DOG THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS TODAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
MADAM PRETEND- I DO APOLOGIZE
FOR BEING LATE I MIGHT I MIGHT
HAVE MISSED SOME UESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED AND SO I APOLOGIZE
IF I ASK THEM AGAIN. ONE YOU
DID. TALK ABOUT THE OIL
INDUSTRY AND FARMING INDUSTRY
NO OLDER DURING COUNTY. ONLY
KERN COUNTY SAN. SO MY SENATOR
THERE HAS SAYS THAT HE COVERED
MY DISTRICT SO- BUT I'M GONNA
NOT TAKE THAT CHANCE AND
CONTINUE TO ASK MY QUESTIONS IF
IT'S OKAY WITH THE GOOD SENATOR-
MY QUESTION IS- OBVIOUSLY A.
FOR THE DIRECTOR BUT ALSO- YOU
KNOW FOR ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO
ANSWER- THE GOVERNOR RECENTLY A
DUD DIRECTED IT OR LET ME KNOW
SORRY WHAT YOU DID MISS IS
WE'RE DO AND OTHER CHAIR ON HER
OWN IN FIRST AND SO WE WILL
MOVE TO THE OTHERS AFTER WE
FINISH SO THAT'S GOOD NEWS FOR
YOU YOU WON'T CUT IT YOU CAN
JUST FOCUS DIRECTLY WITH HER
AND THEY KNEW THAT BOTH YOU AND
SENATOR CALM WATER HAD BUDGET
SUB SO PEOPLE ARE AWARE. ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SO M. MADAM CHAIR
THE GOVERNOR RECENTLY DIRECTED
A OR B. TWO ABOUT EVALUATE
PHASING OUT OIL AND GAS AND-
YOU'RE A COMING SCHOOL BEING
PLANNED AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN UNDER THE
ROWN ADMINISTRATION YOUR
AGENCY FOUND THAT REASON
RESTRICTING OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION CALIFORNIA. COULD
ALSO RESULT IN THE COST OF A
REGIONAL AND LOCAL ECONOMIES
BEING AFFECTED INCLUDING LOSS
OF EMPLOYMENT AND TAX REVENUE
VITAL TO PROVIDING ESSENTIAL
PUBLIC SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE- FOR INSTANCE KERN COUNTY
NOT ONLY PRODUCES 70% OF THE
STATE'S OIL THAT IS CONSUMED BY
ALL CALIFORNIANS. BUT IT ALSO
PRODUCES 51% OF THE SOLAR THAT
IS CONSUMED BY ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS IN VERY FEW PEOPLE
KNOW THAT BUT OUR SOLAR ISN'T
NORTH AND SOUTH EVEN THOUGH USE
YOUR LAND OUR LAND TIP- PRODUCE
THE SOLAR. ELECTRICITY THAT
HELPS MEET THE GREENHOUSE. GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS. AND
THE PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE IS
WITH OUR OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY
THEY PAY LOCAL TAXES WHERE WE
CAN TAKE CARE OF FIREFIGHTERS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. LIBRARIES
THINGS LIKE THAT- OUR SOLAR
COMPANIES DON'T PAY LOCAL TAXES
AND WE LOSE ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. AND IN.
MANY THAT'S USED TO BENEFIT OUR
COMMUNITY EVEN THOUGH WE- WE
PRODUCE 51% OF THE STATE'S
SOLAR WE GET NO BENEFIT FROM
THAT. SO I'M WONDERING IF- YOU
ANTICIPATE THE FINDINGS FROM
YOUR RESEARCH REPORT DID THEY
CHANGE. AND WILL YOU RELY ON
THE PREVIOUS ANALYSIS WE TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE. THAT LIKE I SAID
PRODUCE 70% OF THE STATE'S OIL
IT HELPS US PREVENT OIL FROM
BEING SHIPPED IN FROM ECUADOR
NICARAGUA. VENEZUELA I MEAN ALL
THESE OTHER PLACES THAT WE HAVE
OIL SHIPPED IN BECAUSE OUR
CONSUMPTION HASN'T GONE DOWN.
AND AGAIN OUR COMMUNITY
PRODUCES 51% OF THE SOLAR BUT
WE GET NO CREDIT FOR IT SO. I
GUESS MY GOING BACK TO THE
EXACT QUESTION IS DO YOU
ANTICIPATE FINDINGS FROM A
RECENT REPORT TO HAVE CHANGED-
WE RELY ON YOUR PREVIOUS
ANALYSIS. IS THEIR DIFFERENCES
AND HOW DO YOU PLAN TO
RECONCILE THEM. SO WE WILL AND
WE WILL LOOK AT PREVIOUS
ANALYSES THAT HAVE BEEN DONE
AND- AND- MORE CURRENT ANALYSIS
THAT AND HAS BEEN DONE MORE
RECENTLY AND- AND I'LL-
RELEVANT AND- AS THAT. IT IS
ECONOMIC AND TECHNICAL ANALYSIS
THAT WE CAN IS KIND OF THE
SHORT AFTER YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE AND-
GATHERING THE BEST DATA- TO
HELP US DO THIS WORK- IN THE IN
THE PLAN ITSELF WE WILL BE
ANALYZING- PURSUANT TO THE- THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUEST- IT.
STRATEGIES AROUND- GETTING TO
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY PACOLLI
BOTH SUPPLY AND DEMAND CAN YOU
RAISE THE KEY ISSUE IN YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT- CONCEPTION- AND
SO I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT STEPPING PLAN
TO- ANALYZE WAYS THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY BOTH
LOOKING AT SUPPLY AND DEMAND-
SO THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND WAYS
THAT WE CAN TRANSITION AWAY
FROM FOSSIL FUELS IN- IN OUR
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES WITHIN THE
STATE- SO WILL BE ANALYZING-
YOU KNOW BOTH OF THOSE STATES-
VERY THOROUGHLY AND- AND WE
WILL CERTAINLY BE LOOKING AT.
ECONOMIC AND- THAT THEIR TAX BY
UP. THANK YOU I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TO ASK YOU A FEW
QUESTIONS IF YOU DON'T MIND ON
TRANSPORTATION AND IN GHG
EMISSIONS- I HOPE THAT'S OKAY.
SO WHAT FACTORS ARE YOU GONNA
CONSIDER WHEN EVALUATING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICIES SCIENCE BASED
COLLECTIVE LIKE I EVEN- SCIENCE
BASED ARE COST EFFECTIV
REGULATIONS TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
MARKET BASED STRATEGIES. TO
REDUCE M. GHG- SO WE- WILL BE
RELYING ON- AS MUCH AS AT
MODELING AND ANALYSIS AS WE CAN
WITH REGARDS TO UNDERSTANDING-
WHAT EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS WE
WILL BE ACHIEVING- THROUGH
VARIOUS STRATEGIES. AND HOW AND
IT. DEPLOYING ARE
TRANSPORTATION GOLD IN ALL OF
OUR SECTORS THE HEAVY DUTY
SECTOR THE LIKE THE SECTOR OFF
ROAD- YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THEIR
STRATEGIES- THAT WILL REDUCE
GHG EMISSIONS REDUCTION- WILL
ALSO BE LOOKING AT THINGS LIKE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED WHICH
IS. NOT NOT FULLY- PART OF
CARBS JURISDICTION IN TERMS OF
THE STRATEGIES THAT WE WANT TO
IDENTIFY- AND- AND TO DISCUSS
THE POTENTIAL STRATEGIES. THAT
WOULD- YEAH CUCURBITA BY TWENTY
FIVE. OKAY SINCE YOU BROUGHT IT
LEGAL MAS TRAVEL AND I KNOW
THERE'S A SENATOR IN THIS
BUILDING THAT REPRESENTS I
THINK TWENTY SIX SQUARE BLOCKS
OF LOS ANGELES TWENTY SIX
BLOCKS YOU COULD WALKER
DISTRICT- A. I. DRIVE. EIGHT
HUNDRED MILES A WEEK BECAUSE MY
DISTRICT FROM MY DISTRICT
OFFICE TO THE FOR THIS SOUTHERN
SOUTHEASTERN PART OF MY
DISTRICT. IS FIVE HOURS AND
FORTY SIX MINUTES. FROM THE
MOST EAST PART OF MY DISTRICT
NOT SEVENTY SOUTHEAST BUT THE
MOST EASE PART IT'S TWO HOURS
AND FORTY FIVE MINUTES. AND
THEN TO THE WEST IT'S AN HOUR
AND FIFTY MINUTES INTO THE
NORTH IT'S AN HOUR AND FORTY
MINUTES. SO I PUT SEVEN HUNDRED
MILES A WEEK AT MINIMUM ON MY
CAR JUST DRIVING BACK AND FORTH
FROM SACRAMENTO BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE YOUR TRAVEL. FROM
BAKERSFIELD TO S. SACRAMENTO.
AS THE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
TO PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY WHICH
SEEMS TO BE ON THE TARGET LIST
A LOT. AND YEAH. IT IS
FRUSTRATING TO ME A. N. I'M
JUST SHARING MY FRUSTRATION
WITH YOU IS THAT. WE ARE A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS TO DRIVE THE
MOST MILES IN THE STATE BECAUSE
WE'RE A RULE EVERYWHERE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. WE PRODUCE-
WE'RE THE SECOND LARGEST FOOD
PRODUCER IN THE ENTIRE WORLD MY
DISTRICT PRODUCES ALL THE FOOD
THAT YOU GUYS EAT. AND BUT
FARMERS ARE ATTACKED AND THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD- ACTUALLY DOES%
HAVE- A LOT OF POLICIES AND I
REALIZE IT WERE BROUGHT FORTH
BY THIS BUILDING INNER FALLING
REGULATORY PROCESSES. THAT WERE
INSTITUTED IN POLICY. BUT
THEY'RE STRUGGLING NOW YOU KNOW
THEY HAVE TO REPLACE VEHICLES
AND EQUIPMENT. THAT IS FOUR
YEARS OLD IN THIS EQUIPMENT WAS
MEANT TO LAST FOR. YEARS I MEAN
TWENTY YEARS YOU KNOW COTTON
JENNER THAT YOU KNOW IF FOUR
THOUSAND OUR PIECE OF EQUIPMENT
IT SHOULD LAST TWENTY YEARS NOT
FOUR YEARS. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO AND THEN OF
COURSE THE OIL INDUSTRY WHICH
I'M VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT AND-
BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE USING IT AND
IF WE DON'T PRODUCE IT HERE
SAFELY AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY. IN THE MOST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY EVER AND WE'RE GONNA
GET IT FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES AND BRING
IT OVER HER BY BUNKER FUEL
WHICH- CAUSES MORE GEE SHEEN IN
ANYTHING EVER- PRODUCED
INCLUDING DIESEL TRACKS. M. SO
GOING TO CAP AND TRADE BASED ON
THAT COMMENT AND I'M SORRY FOR
THAT LEGALLY COMMENT AND- GOING
TO CAP AND TRADE. IN YOUR VIEW
WHAT THE WHAT WHAT HOW LARGE OF
A ROLE DO YOU THINK THAT CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAMS. HAVE A TV
IN THE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS.
SO THAT IS A KEY ISSUE WILL BE
WE WILL BE LOOKING AT IN THE
SCRIPTING PLAN IN TERMS OF-
UNDERSTANDING- WHAT ARE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES ARE AND
HOW MUCH- EMISSIONS REDUCTION
WE CAN ACHIEVE. WITH EACH
STRATEGY THAT WILL BE A KEY
FOCUS OF THE ANALYSIS IN THE
UPCOMING SKIPPING PLAN. OKAY DO
YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON HOW
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM- COULD BE
IMPROVED. I THINK THAT. THERE
ARE AS AND I WAS MENTIONING
EARLIER MAYBE LIKE YOU RAN YOUR
OTHER HEARING AND HE HAD A CAP
AND TRADE STRUCTURE AND- THE
REGULATORY STRUCTURE GOES WITH
IT HAS EVOLVED OVER THE YEARS-
RIGHT NOW AND WE ARE SORT OF
TAKING THE PROGRAM AS IT IS- WE
RECENTLY MADE CHANGES IN
RESPONSE TO LEGISLATION- AND SO
THAT THOSE CHANGES- HAVE
RECENTLY GONE INTO A FACT AND-
WE'RE UNDERTAKING ARE SCOPING
PLAN ANALYSIS. AND THEN AFTER
THAT- YOU KNOW I THINK WE WOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
WHAT IT CHANGES IF ANY WE
SHOULD CONSIDER MAKING- TO THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM- OKAY.
WHEN DO YOU THINK THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL BECOME CARBON
NEUTRAL. PERFECT I DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION.
ASIDE THROUGHOUT THEIR. I DON'T
EITHER OKAY. ALL QUIT QUIT AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU MA'AM FOR
YOUR M. QUESTIONS FOR ANSWERING
MY QUESTIONS AND AGAIN I'M
SORRY I'M VERY DEFENSIVE ABOUT
MY COMMUNITY THAT SEEMS TO BE
UNDER ATTACK BY ALL AGENCIES IN
THIS BUILDING. N. M. ALL'S WE
ARE DOING IS TRYING TO MEET
THAT HELP THE GOVERNOR NEEDS
CLIMATE GOALS AT LIKE I SAID
51% OF THE STATE'S OIL IS
GENERATED FROM MY COUNTY ONE
COUNTY- AND- ANNA. IT'S
FRUSTRATING THAT IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE IT'S CONSTANTLY UNDER
ATTACK. SO I APPRECIATE YOU
ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR. OF HAVING THE
COURAGE TO TAKE ON THIS ROLE
THAT YOU ARE GETTING READY YOU
ARE ASSUMING. THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR GROWTH THANK YOU WE DO
KNOW ARE YOUR PASSION ABOUT
YOUR COMMUNITY AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR DIPLOMACY. YOU ASKED
TOUGH QUESTIONS- I WAS SERIOUS
IN THAT REMARK- LET ME LET ME
DO THIS WHILE WE KIßM BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW WHEN PEOPLE WILL
BE CALLED THE WAY WITHOUT
RESPECT. MADAM CHAIR CAN I ASK
THE SECRETARY TO OPEN THE ROLE
IF YOU'RE READY SENATOR GROWTH
WE DID- WE DID SOME CONSENT
ITEMS WHICH WERE- GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR WE DID NOT SEPARATE THE
VOTES FOR I DID TOO. F. AND G.
SO THEY WERE TOGETHER- AND ITEM
NUMBER THREE THE BILL WERE FOR
OLD CAN WE OPEN THOSE AND ADD
ON YOUR VOTE AT THIS POINT OKAY
ABSOLUTELY JUST IN CASE-
SOMEONE HAS TO LEAVE AGAIN
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU OPEN
THE ROLE ON ITEM. TWO F. AND G.
GROVE I RUFAI FIVE TWO ZERO
FIVE TWO ZERO- THAT IS OUT
THANK YOU AND ITEM THREE. ROW
FIVE GROUP HI FIVE TWO ZERO
FIVE ZERO THE BILL REFERRALS
ARE OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANKS FOR LETTING ME DO THAT
AND SENATOR COM LAGER I'M NOW
COMING TO YOU FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS- FOR CHAIR RUTH
RANDOLPH RANDOLPH THANK YOU
MADAM. PRO TEM AND GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN SECRETARY- I HAD THE
GOOD FORTUNE OF BEING ABLE TO-
FIRST CHAT WITH YOU WHEN YOU
CAME TO OUR- CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. AND
EVERYONE WAS THRILLED ABOUT
THIS APPOINTMENT AND OF COURSE
WE TWO ARE QUITE PASSIONATE
ABOUT. ISSUES IMPACTING OUR A
DISTRICT IN THE WORK- AND THE
LEGACY OF CARP SO. I KNOW MY-
CALLING FROM SANTA CRUZ ASKED
THIS QUESTION WHILE I WAS GONE
SO- FEEL FREE TO. NOT REPEAT
YOURSELF BUT- THERE HAVE BEEN A
COUPLE OF CRITICISMS THAT HAVE
BEEN LEVIED- AT CAR PROBABLY
MORE THAN TWO BUT I'LL JUST
RAISE TWO- ONE IS THAT IT PLAYS
TO AN INTERNATIONAL AUDIENCE
AND NOT TO EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THAT THE SECOND IS- THAT
IT'S RUN BY STAFF AND OVER THE
BOARD- AND SO JUST WANTED TO
KNOW IF YOU COULD SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THESE CRITICISMS
AND THE TONE THAT YOUR
LEADERSHIP IS GOING TO TAKE
PROBABLY AND- YOU KNOW MAYBE
COURSE CORRECTING- SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS OR- YOU KNOW
PAST AGGRESSIONS. AND YES SO
THAT WHICH REGARD TO OUR
INTERNATIONAL VERSUS IN STATE
FOCUSED I THINK HIGHER. HAS
NOT- HAS NOT WAVERED FROM THE
IN STATE FOCUS THAT WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO. ADOPT REGULATIONS
AND ENFORCE THOSE REGULATIONS
THAT ADDRESS. AIR POLLUTION
AND- THATIS THE PATRICK'S
HERE- IN OUR COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA- WE BY FAR MOST OF
OUR EMPLOYEES AT THE AGENCY
WORK ON- THOSE KIND OF BREAD
AND BUTTER- AIR QUALITY ISSUES-
AND THEY'RE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE AGENCY AND
WILL. CONTINUE EVERYTHING AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE FRIEND AT FROM
HOUSING GOING VESSELS TO
FERRIES TO OPERATE EQUIPMENT-
BOTH I REGULATORY PROGRAMS AND
OUR INCENTIVE PROGRAMS ARE
REALLY- INTENDED TO REDUCE-
OZONE AND PARTICULATE MATTER-
AND- AND- DO THE BEST WE CAN
TO. ACHIEVE CLEAN AIR ACT ACT
THE PAYMENT IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT CONTINUES. TO BE A KEY
FOCUS AND IT'S ALSO SOMETHING
THAT I FEEL- I CAN THAT. AB
SPEND MORE TIME CAP ABOUT AND A
LITTLE MORE TIME HIGHLIGHTING
BECAUSE I REALLY DON'T WANT
WANT FOLKS TO FORGET THAT THAT
WORK IS HAPPENING- WHICH REGARD
TO AND- THAT YOU KNOW THAT
STAFF AND THE BOARD I THINK- WE
ARE AT A VERY LARGE BOARD AND-
AND WE HAVE. A LOT OF EXPERTISE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE AS- AND I THINK ONE
OF MY GOALS AS CHAIR IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT BOARD MEMBERS HAVE.
ACCESS TO ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE
DECISIONS THAT. BASS MAKE
THEMSELVES AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE
THREE THINGS- AND TAKE INPUT.
FROM BOARD MEMBERS AND SO I
HOPE THAT IF ANY BOARD MEMBERS
FEEL LIKE THAT'S NOT HAPPENING
THAT THEY WILL REACH OUT TO ME.
AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO TRY TO
INTERVENE AND MAKE SURE THINGS
RUN MORE SMOOTHLY- BUT I ALSO
THINK THAT. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY IN OUR MONTHLY AND
CONTAINS MORE THAN MONTHLY
MEETINGS Q. AND- REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT BOARD MEMBERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THEIR
THOUGHTS AND SHARE THEIR
LEADERSHIP. IT'S CHALLENGING
BECAUSE- AND- WHEN YOU HAVE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT MEMBERS THEY
HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
TO YOU. AND AND SO IT WOULD BE
DIFFICULT IF BOARD MEMBERS WERE
SORT OF CALLING UP STAFF AND
HAVING THEM. IT'S DIFFERENT
ACTIONS THAT MAY NOT REFLECT
THE CONSENSUS REPORT SO AS A
RESULT THAT REALLY NEEDS IS
VERY IMPORTANT IN OUR BOARD
MEETING AND THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO GAIN AT A
COLLECTIVE UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THE BOARD DIRECTION IS AND
WHAT THE NEXT STEPS ARE THAT WE
EXPECT. FOR STAFF- AND SO IT'S
MICHAEL IN RUNNING THE MEETING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO HAVE
THAT- ROBUST INTERACTION- AND
THAT WE'RE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE ACTION THAT WE WANT TO
PROVIDE TO STAFF. OR THANK YOU
FOR THAT- YOU KNOW PART OF THE
QUESTION WAS ALSO BASED ON.
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE- OF WORKING
ON POLICIES AND- ACTUALLY.
BEING SO FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
HAVE- THE PRO TEM BE HELPFUL TO
SOME OF THAT BUT NEEDING THAT
EXTRA PUSH BECAUSE OF- THE
BUREAUCRACY- AT THE A. R. B.
AND- GETTING THE DISTINCT
FEELING THAT IT WAS NOT REALLY
DRIVEN BY- BOARD POLICIES- BUT
BY OTHER ENTIIES AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO SORT OF. YOU KNOW
ELEVATE THAT BUT I AM TRUSTING
IN THIS NEW LEADERSHIP AND IN
YOUR VISION. NOT VERY MUCH SO.
OKAY SO I FEEL LIKE I'M GONNA
YOU KNOW ASK THE BLACK PEOPLE
QUESTION- BECAUSE THERE WAS A
LETTER THAT WAS SHARED- QUITE
WIDELY WRITTEN BY- BLACKSTAFF I
THINK WHEN I ASKED YOU THIS
QUESTIONI ALSO SAID THAT I
HOPE THAT THERE WAS NO
RETALIATION HAPPENING AGAINST
THEM BECAUSE OFTEN TIMES ARE
VERY KEEN ARE YOU CAN COUNT THE
NUMBER OF. FOLKS OF COLOR ON
YOUR HAND AND SO IT'S KIND OF
EASY TO FIGURE OUT WHO WROTE
WHAT AND SIGNED WHAT EVEN IF
THEY WANT TO BE ANONYMOUS. BUT
THE LETTER SPEAKS TO- A NUMBER
OF ISSUES M. AND ON A NUMBER OF
LEVELS- AND REALLY YOU KNOW
MICROAGGRESSION THAN BIAS EAST
RIGHT- WITH REGARDS TO HOW
PEOPLE ARE TREATED HOW THEY ARE
SEEN. AND HOW THEY ARE VALUED.
AND THAT OFTENTIMES GENERALLY
ALSO TRANSLATES INTO-
PROGRAMMING- AND FUNDING AND
HOW COMMUNITIES ARE SEEN AND
TREATED AND VALUED- WHICH THEN
CAN LEAD DOWN THE ROAD TO YOU
KNOW WHO'S GETTING FUNDING HOW
COMMUNITIES ARE MARGINALIZED
ETCETERA SO. WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
SORT OF YOUR THOUGHTS ON- WHAT
HAS TRANSPIRED SINCE- THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE LETTER I
KNOWTHERE WAS THE DARE
CHALLENGE AND THERE'S BEEN SOME
INTROSPECTIVE AND INTROSPECTION
THERE WAS THIS CARP RESOLUTION.
THOSE ARE ALL GREAT BUT WOULD
JUST SORT OF LIKE TO HEAR YOUR
RESPONSE ABOUT ALL OF THOSE
THINGS SO IT'S AS MUCH ABOUT
THE INTERNAL POLICIES AND
PRACTICES YES AND STAFF AND
THEN SORT OF HOW THAT'S
TRANSLATING INTO PROGRAMMING-
THAT SUPPORTIVE OF COMMUNITIES.
ACROSSTHE STATE WHO PROBABLY
FEEL LIKE CAR DOESN'T KNOW WHO
THEY ARE- YEAH THE LETTER- FROM
THE BLACK EMPLOYEES WAS A
EXPECT EXPEDIENCY YOU KNOW HOW
MANY PEOPLE SUFFER IN SILENCE
AND DON'T SAY ANYTHING AND TO
HAVE THOSE EMPLOYEES PICK UP
THE MAYOR. THAT REFLECTED BACK
AT THE AGENCY AND SAY YOU NEED
TO CHANGE- IS IT WILL. SO
IMPORTANT AND SO- MEANINGFUL TO
ME. PERSONALLY AS I COME IN AND
TAKE THIS THIS ROLE ONLINE- WE
HAVE A LOT TO DO AND A LONG WAY
TO GO BUT WE- ARE. I BELIEVE US
TO A GOOD START BEFORE I CAME
TO THE AGENCY- KEY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FORM COULD BE AT THAT
THEIR TASK FORCE- AND THEY
BEGAN WORKING ON THINGS SUCH
AS- ROLLING OUT AN IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING LOOKING AT
INTERVIEW PANELS AND HOW THOSE
CAN BE. IMPROVED AND FURTHER-
THAT DIVERSITY- LOOKING AT
RECRUITMENT- OPPORTUNITIES TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE MAKE OUR
CREATE A RECRUITMENT MORE
PRIDE- AT LOOKING AT- YOU KNOW
BEYOND THE USUAL PLACES AND
REALLY- BEING INTENTIONAL- IN
IN WELCOMING- A WIDER VARIETY
OF APPLICANTS AS POSSIBLE- AND
REALLY ELEVATING THE DISCUSSION
OF RACE THROUGHOUT THE AGENCY-
THAT TASK FORCE HAS SPONSORED-
THESE AMAZING PANELS WHERE AT
EMPLOYEES- JUST TALK ABOUT
THEIR EXPERIENCES IN LIFE AND
AT HIGHER- AND- YOUR POINT YOU
KNOW TO THE MICROGRAPHS
INDICATE EXPERIENCE. THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'VE HAD-
AND DOES. HAVE BEEN- REALLY AN
I BENEFITS I Q. CAN MANY OF AT
AGENCY- WHAT ONE MORE INTERNAL
NOTES AND YOU KNOW OUR
EXECUTIVE OFFICER COREY HAS
ASSEMBLED AN INCREDIBLY DIVERSE
SENIOR LEADERSHIP TEAM OUR OUR
STRUCTURE IS THAT THE BOARD
CHOOSES THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
EXECUTIVE OFFICER THAN TO TEAM
AS- DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER
TO- HE SUPERVISED AT WORK AND-
THAT TEAM IS- BIT HAS BEEN- YOU
KNOW INCREASED AND NEARLY-
CONSTITUTED- OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS AND IT'S A TEAM OF
INCREDIBLY EXPERIENCED. AND
TALENTED PEOPLE WHO- WHO LOOK
LIKE CALIFORNIA- AND THAT IS.
THAT LEADERSHIP IS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED- WHICH FOR. TO THE
EXTERNAL ISSUES I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT YES- IF AN AGENCY IS NOT.
UNDERSTANDING THE LIVES AND THE
LIVED EXPERIENCE OF UNDER
REPRESENTED PEOPLE THEN IT IS
NOT VERY DIFFICULT PICTURE.
PEOPLE AND SO AND THE- THINK
ABOUT- WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES. I THINK THE WAY I
EIGHT- VIEW IT IS THE FIRST
STEP IS TO LISTEN TO
COMMUNITIES AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEIR ISSUES ARE AND WHAT THE
CHALLENGES ARE AND IN THEIR-
AT. THAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
NOT TO ASSUME THAT WE KNOW SORT
OF WHAT THE SOLUTIONIS AND
WHAT THE AND WITH THE RIGHT
STRATEGY IS- BUT TO REALLY MAKE
IT A MORE OF A COLLABORATIVE
DISCUSSION- I WAS TALKING TO-
AND ACTIVISTS THE OTHER DAY.
THAT THAT- THAT FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES ARE THE ONES WHO
LIVE WITH THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. AND SO IN
DEVELOPING OUR REGULATORY WORK
AND OUR PROGRAMMING IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO- UNDERSTAND WHAT
THOSE POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ARCH- AND THE ONLY
WAY YOU CAN DO THAT IS BY
REALLY HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE COMMUNITY AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE
COMMUNITY WANTS AND HOW THOSE-
THAT. PROGRAMS ARE AFFECTING
THOSE COMMUNITIES- AND SO I'M
REALLY- I HAVE BEEN IMPRESSED
WITH THE TEAM WE HAVE HERE- AT
CARP WORKING ON A IN OUR
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION- AT
OUR OFFICE IF YOU NEED A YEAR
PROTECTION- AND- AND I HOPE
THAT OUR CONTINUED WORK- WITH
REGARD TO- SCOPING PLAN AND-
EIGHTY SIX POINT SEVEN AND ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WE
ARE. IN COMMUNITIES AND
INTERACTING- AND BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS BECAUSE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS ON TOPICS AROUND-
A LOCAL AND- RECEIVING A- IT
MIGHT MIGHT ALSO YOU KNOW YOU
WANT YOU YOU YOU WANT MAY WANT
TO HAVE ANOTHER CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE TRACKS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY OR OTHER ISSUES THEIR
THING IN THE COMMUNITY- AND SO
AVOIDING THE SILOS OF ALL OF
OUR DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AND
REALLY TRYING TO ENGAGE. WITH
COMMUNITIES ABOUT THE TOPICS
THAT THAT THEY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT- IS THAT- I THINK THE
BEST WAY WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
AND IMPROVE THE WAY WE WORK
WITH COMMUNITIES. WELL YOU KNOW
I COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE
ON THAT I DO WANT TO SAY AS YOU
WERE. TALKING I LOOKED I
SCROLLED ON DOWN THE WEBSITE
AND- DEFINITELY HAVE. A- A
GROUP OF LEADERS ON YOUR
EXECUTIVE TEAM THAT ARE
REFLECTIVE OF CALIFORNIA BUT I
JUST CAUTION THAT WOULD YOU
KNOW AS I TRY TO TELL MYSELF
THAT WE THINK OUTSIDE OF THE
BOX BECAUSE YOU YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE A SISTER WHO'S HANDLING E.
J. SO THAT'S ALWAYS LIKE
PUTTING A BLACK PERSON IN
CHARGE OF DIVERSITY- AND THEN
YOU HAVE A SISTER IN TURN. IN
TERMS AT RUNNING INTERNAL
OPERATIONS AND THAT SORT OF
MAKES ME THINK OF THE GS AND WE
HAVE CERTAINLY A WHOLE BUNCH OF
FOLKS OF COLOR. MAKING SURE
THAT OUR OFFICES ARE CLEAN- BUT
WE DO PEOPLE OF COLOR DO FAR
MORE THAN THAT- AND SO. IF WE
CAN EXPAND OUR- OPTIONS TO BE
MORE INCLUSIVE IN WAYS THAT MAY
MAKE SOME OF US UNCOMFORTABLE-
I THINK THAT'S WHEN WE HAVE
MUCH MORE RICH DISCUSSIONS-
WHICH LEADS INTO WHAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT ABOUT
COMMUNITIES. AND THEREFORE
LISTENING WE SEE HOW ROBUST AND
VIBRANT- AND NON MONOLITHIC-
COMMUNITIES ARE AND THEIR NEEDS
ARE- YOU KNOW I TRUST. THAT
UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP THE BOARD
WILL BE DRIVING THE POLICIES.
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON
CALIFORNIANS- AND THAT WILL
REALLY PRIORITIZE THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SUFFERING
FROM- POLLUTION HERE. AND I
JUST. YOU KNOW AS YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT AVOIDING SILOS.
WHEN I THINK I. WAS REFLECTING
ON AN ARIAL TOUR THAT I TOOK
OF MY DISTRICT AND THEN THE
SOUTHERN PART OF THE DISTRICT I
SAW NO TREES. BUT I SAW SO
MANY- CONCRETE SIDEWALKS AND
ROOFS THERE WERE NO GREEN
CANOPIES. THERE ARE NO E. V.
FACILITIES- THERE WERE NO
INNOVATIVE HUBS- AND WHEN I
WENT TO THE NORTHERN PART IN
THE WESTERN PART OF THE
DISTRICT I COULD EVEN SEE HOMES.
BECAUSE OF HOW- AGGRESSIVE YOU
KNOW THE GREEN CANOPY IS BUT
AND I CERTAINLY SAW THE
INNOVATIVE HOBBS I'M AN EEEE
FACILITIES WHERE FOLKS ARE IN
THESE OFFICES THINKING AND
DREAMING OF A WAY- TO CREATE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL GREEN AND
CLEAN CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW THE
SOUTHERN PART OF THE DISTRICT
WANTS CLEAN AIR TO. THEY WANT
CLEAN JOBS THEY WANT TO BUILD
THOSE JOBS THEY WANT TO BUILD
THE FACILITIES WITH THAT KIND
OF TECHNOLOGY IS BEING
INVESTIGATED AND THEY WANT TO
BUY THOSE PRODUCTS RIGHT AT
PRICES THAT THEY CAN AFFORD.
AND SO YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT
ALSO HAS THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF FOLKS WERE UNEMPLOYED.
PEOPLE WANT TO WORK. AND THEY
WANT CLEAN AIR AND CLEAN WATER
AND SO I'M JUST ASKING THAT YOU
ALL NOT FORGET DON'T FORGET
ABOUT BAKERSFIELD I KNOW SANTA
CRUZ WON'T LET YOU FORGET ABOUT
SANTA CRUZ BUT DON'T FORGET
ABOUT SOUTH LA. YOU KNOW I GO
TO MY BOOTH WHO SAID HE HAD TO
GET MY SUB BRANDS AND ALL THAT
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT CARD
THEY THINK YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
YOUR DIET AND THAT SHOULD NOT
BE THAT SHOULD NOT BE THE CASE-
SHOULD FEEL LIKE CARB. IS
LOOKING OUT FOR THEM REGARDLESS
OF THEIR ZIP CODE AND SO I'M
JUST ASKING YOU. ON BEHALF OF
MY DISTRICT AND C. L. B. C.
THAT YOU TAKE THAT BACK TO CARP.
BECAUSE WHEN WE ARE WANTING
CARP TO STAND FOR US. THANK YOU
MAY I AGREE THANK YOUNG. WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I WOULD
SAY THAT A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ASKED
THAT IS ALWAYS THE BENEFIT OF
GOING LAST I MIGHT ADD- I HAVE
TO SAY I. YOU'VE SERVED AT THE
C. P. U. C. YOU'RE NOW AT- CARB
YOU KNOW YOU JUST NEED TO ADD
THE COASTAL COMMISSION AND
YOU'LL HAVE THE TRIFACTA OF
AGENCIES THAT PEOPLE LOVE TO
CRITICIZE- BUT REALLY DUE TO
THE IMPORTANT YET COMPLEX RULES
REGULATIONS- THAT YOU HAVE TO
OVERSEE THAT REALLY IMPACT OUR
EVERYDAY LIVES AND I JUST HAVE
TO SAY- YOU OBVIOUSLY LIKE A
CHALLENGE- YOU OBVIOUSLY.
BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO TAKE
THAT ON AND TO FOLLOW ALONG
WITH WHAT MY- TO COLLEAGUES WHO
MORE RECENTLY SPOKE. YOU KNOW I
REPRESENT COMMUNITIES THAT
INCLUDE THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO
NEXT TO BAR YOU LOGIN WHERE-
YOU KNOW COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
HAVE LIVE THERE AND THEY DEAL
WITH THE ENVIRO CREEN AND- THEY
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION TO. ALL OF
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO HELP THOSE
COMMUNITIES. BUT I ALSO GREW UP
IN A IN A PLACE MUCH LIKE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND LIKE
BAKERSFIELD WHERE- YOU KNOW YOU
GOTTA UNDERSTAND THAT
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT YET. ABLE
TO TRANSITION- INTO NEW
ECONOMIES- MY DAD WAS A COAL
MINER SO YOU KNOW WHEN YOU TAKE
AWAY THE WHOLE INDUSTRY OUT OF
SOUTHWEST VIRGINIA AND WEST
VIRGINIA. YOU'VE GOT TO BE
AWARE OF WHAT YOU DO AS AS
GOVERNMENT TO ACTUALLY REPLACE
OR TO TRANSITION IN A WAY THAT
IS RESPECTFUL TO PEOPLE WHO
COME OUT OF THOSE INDUSTRIES-
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD. YOU KNOW SHE
TALKED ABOUT THE COTTON JENNER.
AND THOSE PIECES OF EQUIPMENT
AND I AM ALWAYS GOING TO BE
REALLY SUPPORTIVE OF TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE PROVIDE THOSE
RESOURCES TO HELP PEOPLE
TRANSITION. I LOOK FORWARD. TO
THE GLOBAL PARTICIPATION AND
ARE GOING AGAIN TO COP TWENTY
SIX. THIS YEAR THE CLIMATE
CHANGE CONFERENCE WERE
CALIFORNIA WENT IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND WE WERE PERCEIVED
AS- YOU KNOW I REMEMBER
GOVERNOR BROWN WAS PERCEIVED TO
BE A ROCK STAR- BECAUSE OF THE
WORK THAT CALIFORNIA DOES- YOU
KNOW YOU HAD A FORMER
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR. THERE YOU
HAD GOVERNOR BROWN YOU HAD OFF
THE CHAIR OF CARB- THERE- ARE
AND AT THE SAME TIME YOU KNOW
THEY LOOK TO CALIFORNIA AND I
LIKE TO SAY WE HAVE THE
SUBNATIONAL. AREAS AND REGIONS
IN CALIFORNIA TO THAT WE HAVE
TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT WE CANNOT
OVERLOOK THESE OTHER
COMMUNITIES- AND LAUD OUR
SUCCESSES IF WE'RE NOT PREPARED
TO. SPEND SOME OF THOSE
RESOURCES AS LIMITED AS THEY
ARE I JUST TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO SUPPORT THOSE
COMMUNITIES SO I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE THOSE COMMENTS BECAUSE I
THINK. OF EVERYBODY IS INVESTED
IN HOW YOU ACT AND YOUR SCOPING
PLAN AND WHAT IT MEANS FOR
THOSE COMMUNITY THEIR COMMUNITY
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND OUR
ABILITY TO HEAR EACH OTHER IS
WHAT I THINK IS MOST IMPORTANT.
AND GIVEN THAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE ASKED ALL THESE OTHER
QUESTIONS- AND INTO WHICH I
THINK YOU ADDRESSED IT IN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT IN TERMS OF.
HOW. YOU'RE GOING TO APPROACH.
THIS IS IN YOUR ROW IS TO HOW
YOU WENT TO WORK WITH OTHER-BOARD TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR-
AGENDAS AND THEIR PRIORITIES I
THINK YOU YOU ADDRESS THAT. I
YOU'RE RESPONDING TO A NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS- AND THEN THEY'LL
THE ONLY QUESTION THAT I COULD
POSSIBLY HAVE LEFT REALLY FROM
ABROAD FIFTY THOUSAND FOOT
LEVEL. IS THE IMPORTANT
FUNCTION OF THE CHAIR- ADVISING
THE GOVERNOR AND COMMUNICATING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
WORK OF THE BOARD AND YOUR ROLE
AND HOW YOU HOPE TO WORK WITH
US AS LEGISLATORS. YOU KNOW I'M
SURE THAT IT WILL BE A JOY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
FORMER US SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES. BUT I HAVE A FEELING
YOU'RE GOING TO GET MORE CALLS
FROM OUR- LEGISLATORS WHO MAYBE
HAVE NOT ENJOYED THAT DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP AND I JUST WANTED
YOU TO MAYBE SPEAK. BRIEFLY AT
IT IS NOT AN EASY TASK THAT YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU IN TERMS OF
ADVISING THE GOVERNOR WITH A-
POWERFUL BOARD OF PEOPLE WHO
COME WITH THE DESIRE TO SERVE
AND TO BE ON THIS BOARD- SO
MAYBE YOU COULD SPEAK A LITTLE%
BIT ABOUT. HOW YOU WOULD SEEK
TO WORK WITH US AS THE
LEGISLATURE. IN YOUR- YEAH YOU
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION-
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S REAL
IMPORTANT- IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO AND MAINTAIN COMMUNICATION
WITHIN THE M. THEY
ADMINISTRATION- IN TERMS OF
WORKING WITH- YEAH MY FORMER
COLLEAGUE AT THE PC- AS YOU
KNOW AS SENATOR BASEMENT YOU
KNOW THEY HAVE- AS A UTILITIES
ARE GOING TO BE DEPLOYING SOME
OF THIS INFRASTRUCTURE WE SEE-
THAT WILL BE COMING IN THE
FUTURE SAID BEING IN
COMMUNICATION WITH THEM BEING
IN COMMUNICATION WITH THE
ENERGY COMMISSION- WHICH IS
DOING. A LOT OF WORK THERE'S SO
MANY OTHER AGENCIES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT FOR CARP TO
COMMUNICATE WITH AND JOE I WILL
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THOSE
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS WHICH
BRINGS ME TO THE LEGISLATURE
WHERE- THERE ARE AT I DO HAVE
SOME EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS BUT
I NEED TO BUILD A NEED TO BUILD
MORE AND I THINK IT DOES- THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES JUST SIT DOWN AND
HAVE DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE
REALLY- AT THE KEY Q. TWO.
GETTING WORK- I WHERE- THE END
MEMBERS ARE COMING FROM AND
THEY CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE IN
THEIR DISTRICT BE WELL TED BE
OPEN AND SAID AND HAVE THE
COVERAGE- AND- I AM AM REALLY
LOOKING FOR TO- GETTING THAT
WORKED- UNDERSTAND THE- THAT
ISSUES. A BUILDING WITH THOSE
REALLY TRYING TO STAY. AND MAKE
SURE IN- AND PROVIDE TO INFER
THAT IS NOT- AND- AND REALLY
TRY TO- UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW
WHAT THE ARE AND THERE'S GOING
TO BE A Y. VARIETY OF PLACE TO
WRITE. IF GOOD BILL WITH A LOT
OF A LOT OF DIFFERENT BUT DID
HE- THAT REALLY TO AND- WHAT
YOU OUR SEEING- IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND WHAT HEARING FROM-
YOU KNOW I LOVE. THE FORGET
THAT YOU WILL IN THAT- SENATOR
AG KAMLAGER CHEST- SHARED YOU
KNOW WITH THE WITH THE- THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE TREE CARE- IT
JUST A STRAIGHT. DAY AS-
DECISIONS THAT BEEN MADE OVER
HERE DECADE THAT. AFFECT PEOPLE
TO THIS- AND- JUST MAKING SURE
I UNDER THAT AND- AND. WAYS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT- I JUST NOT
GOING COMMUNITY WITH COMMUTER
IN SOUTH BUT ALSO. GIVE YOU WHO
ARE THAT. THANK YOU MUCH- TO
RANDY FOR THOSE COMMENTS. I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND TURN TO OF
THE PUBLIC IN WHO MAY WISH
SPEAK SO. OR OPPOSITION- A
REMINDER FOR THE WAY WHO WANT
TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA PHONE
THAT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER WHICH WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN I HOPE. I. 844-291-4185
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN
FOUR NINE SEVEN NINE EIGHT
SEVEN. BUT I AS WE DO THAT
WE'RE GONNA START RIGHT HERE
WITH WITNESSES IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. AND AS YOU COME
FORWARD I'M GOING TO REMIND YOU
TO KEEP YOUR SOCIAL DISTANCING
DO NOT FORM A LINE MAYBE HANG
BACK A BIT IF THERE'S MORE THAN
ONE. ONLY ONE PERSON AT A TIME
AT THE MICROPHONE AND WANT TO
CONCLUDE THE NEXT WITNESS MAY
COME FORWARD. OKAY WELCOME.
BERMAN CHAIR OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAYER I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF CHARGE POINT.
ARE WE ARE DELIGHTED TO BE HERE
TO SUPPORT. THE CONFIRMATION OF
LIANE RANDOLPH TO THE A. R. B.
AS CHAIR- WE'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY OF MEETING WITH
HER. AND WE ARE IMPRESSED WITH-
THE BACKGROUND BUT ALSO HER
SENSE OF WHAT'S BEFORE HER AND
THE IMPORTANT ROLE OF ADOPTING
POLICIES. TO HELP- CALIFORNIA
GET TO EIGHT ZERO EMISSION GOAL
OF- TWENTY THIRTY FIVE OF US
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES. AS I
MENTIONED WE'VE MET WITH HER-
AND- WE- LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER AS A PARTNER.
CHARGEPOINT IN THE OTHER EVEY
CHARGING COMPANIES HAVE A VAST
ARRAY OF EXPERIENCES AND
KNOWLEDGE IN OUTLOOK. WE HOPE
THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO WORK IN A
COLLABORATIVE FASHION. WITH MS
RAND OFF AS WELL AS THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE AARP THANK. YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SEEING NO
FOR. WHICH COME FOR SIR SORRY.
AND THANK YOU FOR IT HERE AND
THIS DO. OUR RULES WELCOME. THE
TERM I THANK YOU MY NAME IS TOM
NOT FROM THE VALLEY AIR NOW
WE'RE NOT THAT OPERATES OF BOTH
AIR QUALITY AND CARBON
REDUCTION PROGRAMS IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND HER TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT CHAIR
RANDOLPH. A WE'RE EXTREMELY
ENCOURAGED BY EVERYTHING SHE
SANG ABOUT IT LOSING IT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ENCOURAGING ALL
THESE PROGRAMS TO EXPAND THE
AREAS THEY'RE MOST NEEDED IN
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- AND
WE'VE WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER AT ALL FOR THE
REST OF THE CARDBOARD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. OKAY SEEING
NO ONE FURTHER HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I'M GOING
TO TAKE A LOOK AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE OUR SECOND ROOM. AND I
SEE THAT THERE'S NO ONE
APPROACHING THE PODIUM IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE SO WITH THAT I'M
GOING TO MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. AND I'M
GOING TO WELCOME OUR MODERATOR
AND ASK THEM- THE MODERATOR TO
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR AND AS WE WAIT ON THE
QUEUE UP I'M GOING TO GIVE SOME
ADDITIONAL- COMMENTS SO TO THE
WITNESSES WE ASK THAT WHEN YOU
SPEAK TO PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR
NAME THE ORGANIZATION IF ANY.
AND THE POSITION ON THE
APPOINTMENT AND AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF OUR COURT REPORTER PLEASE
SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY AND
SUCCINCTLY AND BRIEFLY GO AHEAD
MADAM MODERATOR. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ABOUT NINE IN Q. FOUR TOP
LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S JOHN
KENNEDY I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
WE REPRESENT THIRTY SEVEN OF
THE STATE'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES ALL OF WHICH HAVE
POPULATIONS BETWEEN ELEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS. I'M
HERE TODAY TO OFFER SUPPORT FOR
THE APPOINTMENT OF LIANE
RANDOLPH WE'VE HAD THE PLEASURE
OF WORKING WITH HER WHILE SHE
WAS THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. WE ALWAYS
APPRECIATED- FAIRNESS
THOUGHTFULNESS INSIDE
ESPECIALLY WHEN CONFRONTED WITH
MANY ISSUES LIKE BROADBAND
WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION AND
ENERGY RELIABILITY. THAT ARE
VITAL TO RURAL COMMUNITIES WE
BELIEVE THAT A. R. B. WOULD BE
WELL SERVED BY THE SKILLS AND
APPROACHES THAT SHE BRINGS TO
THE TABLE AND ARE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT HER APPOINTMENT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
THIRTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU- THIS IS JULIAN HERE
VERLANDER ORGANIZATION
BRIGHTLINE DEFENSE IN THE-
SUPPORT OF THE BEING THAT HER.
YOUR PIECE LEVINE I HER FOR HER
PRIOR UNDER JUST NUMBER BURDENS
ON BLACK. LET ME AT EIGHT
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES. AND WILL
QUALITY MONITORING WE
APPRECIATE THEIR RAN BURKE MISS.
TO MEET LOCAL COMMUNITY ECHO
THE OF OUR MY COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE
WERE CAN THAT UP TEST WILL WE
GET TO THE LARGER PANEL OF
OTHER- APPOINT BUT WE PRE THE
CALM ALSO AS A TO. RANDOLPH
WEEK PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PAGE KATHRYN
DR THAT HELPED LEADERS COUNTY
DEAL OF NURSES HELPING. AND WE
HAVE PUT THAT- APPOINTMENT
CHAIR RAMBO AND THE ART BELIEVE
THE THIS IS A REALLY AND HOW
POLICY PLEASE. ON THE FORWARD
TO WITH HER THE OTHER MEMBERS
ON THE SCOPING THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WINTER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ARE YOU ARE
YOU TEAM SCORE. HELLO THE MAN
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNT AND I THINK THAT
THEY'RE ENTITLED AND. WE TO SEE
THE STRONG HEALTH IN A JUSTICE
BY AT THE END OF THE INCOMING
BOARD MEMBER I WOULD LIKE TO BE
CONFIRM. ABOUT PRIVILEGE DOUBLE
TO OUR- FROM MORNING. AND AIR.
WHERE DOES NOT INSURANCE
PROVISION OF USUAL PRACTICES
WHICH ARE AIR AND PEOPLE CAN NO
LONGER BEAR. UNDERSTAND BUT
PEOPLE MY ARE DOT OUR STATE
RECOGNIZE BUT- OF A- TOO.
ACROSS INTO. MOST OF WHICH
THERE WERE BUT LEGAL IN THE-
HIGH LEVEL. ANDREW FORWARD TO
SEEING. OF CLOSER SIXTEEN
RELATIONS WITH COMMUNITIES AND
RELY ON THE TRUE. UPLISTED FROM
WERE. IN THE MOST IMPACT
COMMITTEE. HOPEFUL THE
COURAGEOUS LEADERSHIP FOUND AND
CLEAR BEFORE MEMBERS OFFER THE
STATE. A MEASURE. TO ASSIST
ECONOMY. MORE NATIONAL GUARD
AND IS PROVIDED IN THE LETTER
WITH. WE WILL CONTINUE TO CLEAN
BASED TO QUESTION WORK HARD AND
YOU ALL. THANK YOU. THANK VERY
MUCH AND WE WILL TAKE YOU TEST
OF AS THAT FOR CHAIR RANDALL AS
WELL AS THE NEXT PAY. AUDIENCE
WITH YOUR- ON THE RECORD THANK
YOU MATAMATA NECK WITNESS.
THANK YOU VERY THREE PLEASE GO.
THANK YOU THIS IS KEVIN FROM
THIS CAL HAS LOCAL I. SPEAKING
A OF YOUR RAND OFF AND THE ANIL
TO COME FORWARD- WE APPRECIATE.
END QUESTIONS THAT THE PANEL
HAS. BEEN ASKED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND APPRECIATE THE
PANEL'S COMMITMENT ENSURE
RANDOLPH'S COMMITMENT TO THE
CHANCE OF BOTH ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. AND MOVING- TO CLEAN
THE AIR AND SUPPORT. CLIMATE
CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA SO- WE
STAND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAME
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS DANIELLE
MEL ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
CLEAN POWER CALIFORNIA HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
JERRY BROWN NOT- AROUND UP
KNOWS THE CRITICAL ROLE THAT
THEY'RE REQUESTED FOR BOOKPLATE
AND SETTING TARGETS TO SET THE
COURSE FOR AN EQUITABLE
AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE
TRANSITION 21100% CLEAN ENERGY.
AND WE URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU VERY
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
EILEEN TIED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION WE ARE NONPROFIT. THE
TRANSITION BECAUSE THERE ARE
MISSION VEHICLES AND WE ARE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SURELY AND RANDALL ON THE PANEL.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT I WAS
ASKED BY ANY CHANCE. YOU ALSO
SUPPORT THE CHAIR AND PANEL
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND URGED A
CONFIRMATION OF THE CHAIR AND
PANEL MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU I'M TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT TO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TRYLINE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON
B. MY NAME IS DAN HALL FROM THE
CARROLL SEARCHES. I REQUEST
SENATE CONFIRM THE APPOINTMENT
OF CHAIR RANDOLPH TO THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
DURING YOUR TIME AT THE BUTTE
DEMONS RANDOLPH EXHIBITED
STRONG LEADERSHIP IS WELL
PLACED THE LEAD THE BOARD A
NUMBER OF UPCOMING PROCEEDINGS
INCLUDING REGULATIONS FOR
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS AND
FLEETS. CALIFORNIA IS A GREAT
DEAL OF CONFIDENCE THAT MISS
RANDALL STOP APPROACH TO POLICY
DEVELOPMENT WILL CREATE A
ROBUST ENGAGEMENT FOR MANY
STAKEHOLDERS. IS THERE HER WITH
GREAT ENTHUSIASM THAT WE
RECOMMEND THAT YOU THEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
CONFIRMING. APPOINTMENTS AROUND
ALL. TWO CAR. THANK NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AYE DADDY ON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR COMMUNITIES
TRANSITION BY LINE DEFENSE%
SPEAKING SCRIPTURE RANDOLPH I
WAS A BIT LATE BUT HEARD THAT
THE CEILING MEDIA OF BRIGHTLINE
ACTUALLY TURNED IN SUPPORT OF
COMMENTS WILL BE VERY BRIEF. H.
R. ONE ALSO RECENT OUT TO LOW
INCOME ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY. PARTICULARLY WITH
SAN FRANCISCO CHINATOWN AND
BELIEVE IN OUR LEADERSHIP FROM
BY MENTAL JUSTICE THANKS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU VERY
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS BILL
MCGOVERN WITH THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF YOUR RANDOLPH I
THINK SHE'S OFF TO A VERY GOOD
START AND I'VE BEEN IMPRESSED
WITH THE COLLABORATIVE WAY IN
WHICH SHE'S BEEN STEERING THE
BOARD. BUT WE KNOW THAT CARP
HAS A LOT OF WORK TO DO AS IT
CONFRONTS CALIFORNIA'S TWIN
CRISES OF AIR POLLUTION AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE BELIEVE
THE BOARD SHOULD EMPHASIZE
DIRECT REDUCTIONS IN EMISSIONS
AND MAKE THOSE REDUCTIONS IN A
WAY THAT BENEFITS THE RESIDENTS
OF THE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. WHO SUFFERED FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU VERY FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- NUMBER TEN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE NECROPSY
CALIFORNIA FIGHTERS I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRE FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY- THAT
CALIFORNIA BASED NONPROFIT THAT
ADMINISTERS THE CRP PROGRAM ON
BEHALF OF KERR- WE'RE CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
APPOINTMENT OF CHAIR RANDOLPH
HOW WE GOT A PLEASURE WORKING
WITH HER DURING HER TIME TO
COMMISSIONER AT THAT PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AS WELL.
WE'RE VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE OPPORTUNITY FOCUS ON
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS I
WITH HER EIGHT CARP
ADDITIONALLY WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT WHILE WE'RE
ON THE PHONE. AFTER THE OTHER
CAR BUT- BOARD MEMBERS BEING
CONSIDERED TODAY- THEY BRING A
GREAT BALANCE AND- RANGE OF.
EXPERIENCES AND VIEWPOINTS TO
THE BOARD AND WE THINK- ALL OF
THEM WILL BE AFTER REPORT
NUMBER SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE THANK YOU AND WE WILL NOTE
THAT SUPPORT TO FIVE FOR THE
UPCOMING PANEL AS WELL THANK
YOU MADAM. MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
COMMENT THINK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MADAM MONTEREY WILL
BE BACK WITH YOU IN A FEW
MOMENTS I'M SURE- WE ARE NOW
GOING TO BRING IT BACK AND-
START WITH WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE- OF
FOLKS WHO MIGHT BE IN
OPPOSITION. AND IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE I DO NOT SEE ANYONE
APPROACHING THE DYESS SO I'M
GOING TO LOOK TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. AND THERE IS NO ONE- IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- SO MATAMATA
RAIDER I'M ACTUALLY BACK WITH
YOU RIGHT NOW WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ACTORS TIME. IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ONE IN Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT LINE NUMBER OKAY THANK YOU.
FOR TOTALING FIFTEEN TWO YEARS
AGO I HAD. YEAH ABSOLUTELY- I
AM NOT IN OPPOSITION MY NAME IS
FOR ALL TO READ I AM CULTURE
HERE- WEST OAKLAND BART MILLION
DECATUR'S PROJECT ON- LAND USE
COMMITTEE. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
LEAVE A MARK THE PORT FOR THE
OPEN MINDED AND BROADMINDED
APPROACH OF APPROACHING WITH
EQUITY WILL LOOK LIKE. OR- THE-
RECTOR AN I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
EARMARKED SUPPORT THROUGH-
DIVISION ARE HURT- TO BE- ON
THE BORA BORA WHAT- WHAT THE
AGREEMENT INDICATOR PROJECT AND
I BELIEVE SHE IS A VERY
PROGRESSIVE AND OPEN MINDED. AT
THE REQUEST OF THE OPEN MINDED
APPROACH WHEN IT COMES TO
EQUITY IN REGARDS TO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WELL THANK
YOU VERY. MUCH APPRECIATE. I
YOU SO MUCH WILL READ THEIR S.
OUR A PRE YOUR CALL IN MADAME
DO HAVE ANY ELSE ALL THE LINE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE- WE WILL BE BACK
WITH YOU IN A LITTLE WHILE- IF
I COULD JUST MAKE A COMMENT I
KNOW YOU'RE READY TO GO.
SENATOR ALWAYS CAN COUNT ON
YOU. I JUST WANTED TO BECAUSE I
WILL BE OUT AFTER THIS VOTE I
WILL BE HANDED OFF ONE WEEK
BEFORE WE TAKE A SHORT- FIVE
MINUTE BREAK FOR THE BENEFIT OF
OUR COURT REPORTER- I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE A- COMMENT-
BEFORE I. EXIT- YOU KNOW I WANT
TO THANK THE NEW CHAIR- AND
CERTAINLY- THE PANEL IN THE
BOARD THAT WILL BE UP NEXT FOR
CONVERSATION. I INCLUDING OF
COURSE OUR OWN SENATE
APPOINTMENTS WHO I THINK ARE
REALLY SECOND TO NONE AND THEIR
COMMITMENT TO THE PUBLIC
INTEREST. AT THE SAME TIME WE
KNOW FROM SOME OF THE
DISCUSSION TODAY THAT THERE ARE
HOPES AND DESIRES THAT A. R. B.
FIVE MAYBE TAKES A DIFFERENT
APPROACH AND FOCUS IN A NUMBER
OF AREAS. NOT TO BE UNEXPECTED
BASED ON THE COMMENTS I MADE
BEFORE AND THE DIFFICULT WORK
THAT YOU DO. I DID WANT TO
POINT OUT THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME IN OVER FOURTEEN YEARS
THAT THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
HAS HEARD A CHAIR OF THE BOARD
AND THIS MANY MEMBERS. FOR
CONFIRMATION- NEXT TO CALM. I
IN A WAY IT'S REALLY AN
HISTORIC MOMENT- SINCE WE LAST
HEARD THIS MANY A. R. B.
APPOINTMENTS- ARE NATION STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS BECOME BOTH A
LEADER ON CLEAN AIR AND CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND PERHAPS ITS MOST
PROMINENT VICTIM IN MANY WAYS.
WE'VE HAD THE MOST EXTREME AIR
POLLUTED REGIONS IN THE
COUNTRY. MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUFFER ADVERSE
HEALTH EFFECTS LIKE ASTHMA AND
HEART DISEASE. AND WE ALSO NOW
LIVE WITH EXTREME DROUGHT
WILDFIRES SEA LEVEL RISE AND
POWER OUTAGES ALL FROM THE
EFFECT. OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THESE ARE NOT SIMPLY
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES THEY HIT
VERY HARD AT THE HEART OF OUR
ECONOMY AS WELL. SO I AM
PLEASED TO LOOK AT WHO WE HAVE
BEFORE US TODAY- CERTAINLY
ASSURED AND- THRILLED ABOUT THE
NEW CHAIR. AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING- FROM THE OTHER
MEMBERS- AS THEY TALK ABOUT THE
INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIANS. AT
FIRST AND TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES BETTER. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS TODAY
CHAIR AND WITH THAT I NOW MUST
TURN TO- HI. I WAS GONNA SAY
CHAIR- I HAVE TO DO. IS SENATOR
LAYER TO HAS GREAT HISTORY IN
THESE AREAS IN TERMS OF THE
ISSUES AS WELL AS WITH. THE
APPOINTEE BEFORE US SENATOR
LAYERED I COULDN'T HAVE SAID IT
BETTER THAN THE CHAIR JUST SAID
TO AND I WOULD MOVE THE
APPOINTMENT OF LAND RENT OFF TO
BE CHAIR OF THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. SENATOR THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ROOF I WROTE I
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I LAYERED HI
THERE I BATES. BATES AYE ATKINS.
FIVE SEVEN FIVE ONE ZERO THAT
WAS UNANIMOUS CONGRADULATIONS
TERROR GRANT. AND WITH THAT WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE A- FIVE
MINUTE RECESS- AND WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU THANK YOU
AND TO THOSE WAITING LET ME SEE
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU.
TWENTY IS THERE REQUIRED TO
APPEAR ENOUGH ITEMS WHEN B.
THROUGH E. ON YOUR AGENDA THE
APPOINTMENTS OF FOR MEMBERS TO
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD JOHN
BOMBS HONORABLE THE VIENNA HURT
MEDIAN CRACKLE ANNA TONYA
PACHECO WARNER IN BEFORE WE
BEGAN- JUST WANT TO REPEAT THAT
WE WILL NOT BE TAKING TESTIMONY
ON THESE FOUR WE WILL BE TAKING
TESTIMONY ON THESE FOUR
APPOINTEES TODAY BUT WILL NOT
BE VOTING ON THE APPOINTMENTS
UNTIL OUR NEXT COMMITTEE
MEETING WHEN WE HAVE A FULL A
COMMITTEE MEMBER. ON HERE. SO
WELCOME EVERYONE WILL TAKE UP
THE INTRODUCTIONS IN ORDER THAT
I JUST STATED WHICH IS THE
ORDER OF THE FILE BEGINNING
WITH JOHN BOMBS. DR JON BOMBS
IN AFTER ALL OF YOU HAVE GIVEN
YOUR AND INTRODUCTIONS AND
OPENING COMMENTS I WILL GO TO
MY COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS SO LET US BEGIN WITH
DOCTOR BOND AND I. SEE HIM ON
THERE WELCOME AND IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND
ANYONE WITH YOU WE WELCOME
THOSE INTRODUCTIONS AND THEN-
YOU'RE OPEN TO MAKE YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS- THAT YOU WANT
TO PRESENT TO US- THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR- AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I'M A PHYSICIAN
SCIENTIST WHO HAS BEEN DOING
RESEARCH ON THE HEALTH EFFECTS
OF AIR POLLUTION. FOR OVER
THIRTY FIVE YEARS. I AM HONORED
TO HAVE RECEIVED THE GOVERNOR'S
NOMINATION FOR RE APPOINTMENT
TO BE THE POSITION MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD.
DURING MY TENURE ON THE BOARD I
HAVE TRIED TO BRING A PUBLIC
HEALTH LENDS TO THE AGENCY'S
REGULATORY ACTIONS. I'LL HELLO
ALSO WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. INCLUDING THOSE
WHO LIVE IN COMMUNITIES THAT
SUFFER FROM A DISPROPORTIONATE
BURDEN OF AIR POLLUTION CAN
BREATHE CLEANER AIR. TO THAT
END I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
SIX ONE SEVEN. A GROUNDBREAKING
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE TO SEEK
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AS A BOARD MEMBER
I HAVE CHAIRED THE AB SIX ONE
SEVEN CONSULTATION GROUP. THAT
INCLUDES MEMBERS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCACY.
GROUPS REPRESENTATIVES OF
BUSINESS GROUPS INCLUDING THE
OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY- AND-
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS OFFICERS OF
SEVERAL AIR DISTRICTS THE
CONSULTATION GROUP IS A FORUM
FOR DISCUSSION OF BEST
PRACTICES AND LESSONS LEARNED
ABOUT A. B. SIX ONE SEVEN
IMPLEMENTATION SO FAR IF
CONFIRMED I HOPE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON A. B. SIX ONE SEVEN. TWO
REDUCE HOTSPOTS OF POLLUTION
THAT NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
HEALTH FLOWING COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. I ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TO DEVELOP POLICIES
THAT WILL LEAD TO THE
ACHIEVEMENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER. HAVE ONLY. NEW
LIGHT DTY VEHICLES THAT ARE
ZERO EMISSION SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE AND EVEN MORE AMBITIOUS
TARGETS FOR ZERO EMISSION HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS. FINALLY I ALSO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING AND
RENEWED PARTNERSHIP WITH THE U.
S. EPA. TO ADVANCE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION POLICIES TO
MITIGATE CLIMATE CHANGE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU DR BOMBS. WE WILL
NEXT GO TO HONORABLE THE VIDAK
HURT IN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE ANYONE WITH YOU AYE
AND WE WELCOME THOSE
INTRODUCTIONS AND THEN IT MAKE
ANY OPENING COMMENTS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE. THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR BATES AND I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE WITH ALL OF
YOU AND MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING- MY APPOINTMENT
THIS AFTERNOON. I HAVE
DEDICATED MY LIFE TO LOCAL AND
REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS AS A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER ATTORNEY
PLANNING COMMISSION- BELMONT
COUNCILWOMAN. AND BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
DIRECTOR. FROM THESE
EXPERIENCES I'VE GAINED AN
APPRECIATION FOR BOTH
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZING AND
GOVERNANCE AS A MEANS TO EFFECT
CHANGE THROUGH BALANCED INFORM
PUBLIC POLICY. MY UNDERSTANDING
OF THE IMPORTANCE OF CLEAN AIR
BEGAN AS A CHILD WHERE I WOULD
SPEND SUMMERS WITH MY
GRANDPARENTS IN GARY AND EAST
CHICAGO INDIANA NEXT TO THE
STILL MALES. I KNEW WE WERE
CLOSE TO GRANDMOTHERS ONCE I
ROLLED MY WINDOW DOWN AND COULD
SMELL AIR POLLUTION. I
ASSOCIATE IN MY GRANDPARENTS
HOME WITH THE OWNERS OF THOSE
STILL MALES. I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND AT THE TIME WHY WE
PLAYED INSIDE AUSTIN AND
FRIENDS IN THE COMMUNITY HAD
ASTHMA. TODAY THESE AREAS ARE
SUPERFUND SITES. JUXTAPOSED I
WAS RAISED IN ROCKWALL TEXAS A
SMALL TOWN OUTSIDE DALLAS ON
THE EDGE OF TEXAS FARMING AND
WILL COUNTRY. LIVING IN
ROCKWALL GAVE ME INSIGHT TO
ISSUES THAT FACE RURAL AREAS OF
THE STATE. TODAY I'M IN A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS A SIMILAR
SMALL TOWN FEEL IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE BAY AREA FINANCE LEFT.
THAT WE NEED TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY IN THE COMING YEARS
WITH RESPECT TO HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION IS GOING TO MEET
THE HOUSING NEEDS AND THE
CLIMATE GOALS. THESE
EXPERIENCES HAVE INFORMED MY
INTEREST AND PASSION FOR
PROTECTING HIGHLY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES OFTEN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR COLOR WITH LITTLE.
FINANCIAL SECURITY. ALSO AS A
PRIMARY BLEW WILL REMAIN A PART
OF OUR ENERGY NEEDS FOR SOME
YEARS BUT THE STATE CAN IS
HELPING TO INCENTIVIZE
INNOVATION AND DIVERSIFICATION
OF OUR ENERGY SECTOR.
LEVERAGING CARDS RESOURCES AND
REGULATORY AUTHORITY TO MEET
CLIMATE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE OBJECTIVES WHILE
MAINTAINING AND EXPANDING
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES IS AN
EXCITING PROSPECT. INVESTING IN
NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND INDUSTRIAL
CHANGES CAN NOT ONLY HELP
CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE ITS CLEAN
AIR AND CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS.
ALSO LEAD AND ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL CHEFS TO CREATE AN
ECONOMY AND ENVIRONMENT THAT
BENEFITS GENERATIONS TO COME. I
READ ONCE THAT YOUNG GIRLS WITH
DREAMS BECOME WOMEN WITH VISION
LITTLE DID I KNOW MY TIME AS A
YOUNG GIRL IN INDIANA LATE THE
FOUNDATION FOR MY SERVICE TO
CALIFORNIA AND INSPIRE MY WORK
TO GET IT RIGHT FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN. IT
IS THE CENTRAL FOR US TO
EMBRACE ALL LIVED EXPERIENCES
IN OUR SOLUTIONS AND REACH
CLEAN AIR ATTAINMENT AND ALL OF
OUR REGIONS IF CONFIRMED I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING MY WORK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES THE STAFF.
ALL OF YOU THE LEGISLATURE
SISTER AGENCIES AND THE PUBLIC
TO PURSUE THE AGENCY'S MISSION
WITH A BIGGER AND DEEP
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING THE
LIVES AND LIVELIHOODS. OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU HI MISS HERS WILL NOW GO TO
MISTER KRAKOFF. AND AGAIN-
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND ANYONE
WITH YOU AND WE WELCOME THOSE
INTRODUCTIONS AND THEN I'LL
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR- YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS. THE VICE
CHAIR BATES MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE THAT I WANTED
TO GO UP BEFORE TO BE HEARD.
FOLLOW IT'S AN HONOR FOR ME TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU AGAIN NOW IS
A NOMINEE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD. I WANT TO
THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR
TRUSTING ME WITH THIS
NOMINATION AND MY FAMILY
SOMEWHERE LISTENING AND- MAKING
IT POSSIBLE FOR ME TO PURSUE
PUBLIC SERVICE. EVERYTHING DO A
CAR RETAILER TO OUR MISSION.
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH EFFECTIVE
REDUCTION OF AIR POLLUTION WELL
CONSIDERING AFFECTS THE ECONOMY.
CHEATING COMPLIANCE WITH OUR
FEDERAL AND STATE AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS IS A KEY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE BOARD
ESPECIALLY FOR ME. AS A
DESIGNATED FROM THE SOUTH COAST
AIR DISTRICT WE ARE INVESTING
INCENTIVE DOLLARS AND MUCH WORK
GREENER TECHNOLOGIES
PARTICULARLY FOR HEAVY DUTY
DIESEL TRUCKS TO ADDRESS. OUR
OZONE SMOG CHALLENGE. ANOTHER
PRIORITY IS THE REDUCTION OF
TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS WE HAVE
HAD SUCCESS IN THIS AREA BUT
MORE IS NEEDED. ARE TOXIC WORK
RELATES TO EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
AS DR BOMBS MENTION WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO ACHIEVE LOCAL
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS. KEY
PRIORITY IS TO ENSURE THAT SB
SIX SEVENTEEN LIVES UP TO ITS
PROMISE. SENATORS I WILL BRING
DIVERSE EXPERIENCE AND
PERSPECTIVE. MY TWENTY FIVE
YEAR CAREER AS A LAWYER I WORK
WITH GOVERNMENT INDUSTRY AND
SMALL BUSINESS LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE SECTORS. I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING ON SEVERAL
OTHER STATE BOARDS INCLUDING
THE SOUTH COAST. ISRAEL'S ROLES
EACH ME VALUE OF CIVILITY AND
COLLEGIALITY FELLOW BOARD
MEMBERS AND STAFF. THE VALUE OF
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS BASED ON TRUST AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. YOU SHOW UP TO
THE WORK AND BE RELIABLE TO
HELP MOLD CONSENSUS ON
DIFFICULT ISSUES EVEN AMONG THE
PARTIES WITH DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND PERSPECTIVES.
IS YOUR BASED MEMBERS I'M READY
TO WORK AND IF CONFIRMED BEFORE
TO PARTNERING WITH YOU AND
COURSE NOW TO YOUR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
PROKHOROV OUR FINAL APPOINTEE
TO THE BOARD IS DR TANYA AKHIL
POTATO WARNER. DR PARTICULAR
WARNER IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE ANYONE WITH YOU AND
WE WELCOME THOSE INTRODUCTIONS
AND THEN MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
SHARE WITH US. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND- WHAT ADVICE CHAIR I
JUST ME AS I AM BANKING IN THE
OFFICE AND BY EIGHT THANK YOU
TO HEARING IT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY I
APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE YOUR
STAFFER TAKEN TO MEET.
REGARDING THE ROLE OF MEMBER. I
WENT THINK GOVERNOR YOU SOUND
OFFICE FOR INTERESTING AND
ROLE. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MY HUSBAND ROBERT WAS
BEEN INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE IN
MY EMBARKING ON THIS JOURNEY OF
GOVERNMENT EUROPE TWENTY FIRST
SAN JOAQUIN EVOLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT AND NOW TO CAR. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY
FAMILY OF ORIGINMY PARENTS MY
SIBLINGS IN LAWS I NEED TO IS
WHERE MY CHEERLEADERS. IT
REALLY TAKES A VILLAGE FOR
SOMEONE LIKE ME A MOM OF A
TODDLER AND FIRST GENERATION
IMMIGRANT LATINA TO TAKE ON A
ROLE OF THIS LEVEL OF
RESPONSIBILITY. AND I'M SO
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THEM IN MY
CORNER. I TAKE THIS ROLE ON
WITH A PEOPLE FIRST THEN
PROGRAMS APPROACH. I STRIVE TO
ENSURE THAT WE BEING A BRIGHT
PATH FOR THE FUTURE GENERATION
OF CALIFORNIANS. WHICH INCLUDES
MY SON WHO HAS ASKED NOT WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME ENSURING THAT
WE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY. OUR
ROLE MAKING AFFECTS THE
EVERYDAY PERSON ON THE GROUND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE THINK
ABOUT. EVERYONE FROM THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
OVERBURDENED BY POLLUTION AS
WELL AS THOSE WHO WILL BE MOST
IMPACTED. BY THE FULL
TRANSITION THAT OUR TIME AND
OUR CLIMATE CRISIS
NECESSITATES. A THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL INTO
MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL FOR ARE
STEPPING FORWARD TO THIS VERY
IMPORTANT NOT PUBLIC SERVICE.
ROLE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO PLAY
I'M NOT NOW GOING TO GO TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WILL PROVIDE
SOME QUESTIONS. AND COMMENTS
FOR EACH ONE OF YOU SO LET ME
BEGIN WITH US SENATOR COME
LONGER. THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR AND- THANK YOU- TO EACH
OF YOU- FOR ACTUALLY. GIVING UP
SOME OF YOUR TIME- DR JEKYLL
WARNER I KNOW WE TALKED LONG A
GOOD LONG A FEW MONTHS AGO
MAYBE A WEEK SINCE WHO KNOWS
ABOUT TIME. BUT THE OTHER THREE
WHO ARE UP I KNOW WE SPOKE
YESTERDAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH- I
JUST HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS AND
SO. I WOULD LIKE TO ACTUALLY
DIRECT THE FIRST ONE TO- MISTER
KRAKOFF- GIVEN YOU ARE THE
SOUTH COAST- THANK YOU ANDY- A
POINTY- AND JUST WANTED TO
KNOW. YOU KNOW BEYOND AB SIX
SEVENTEEN YOU KNOW HOW IT IS
CARB SPECIFICALLY WORKING WITH
THOSE AIR DISTRICTS LIKE OURS-
THAT NEED THE MOST HELP. YES
THANK YOU SENATOR AND IT WAS
GOOD TO SPEND SOME TIME. YOU
YESTERDAY AND WE DO HAVE A SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY IN SOUTH
LOS ANGELES- IN YOUR DISTRICT
AND- THAT'S STILL JUST
BEGINNING AND PART OF MY JOB I
THINK IS TO MAKE THAT PROCESS
AS SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE MAKE
SURE THAT EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
LIVES UP. TO ITS PROMISE. THE
CHALLENGE WE HAVE IN THE SOUTH
COAST IS THE ATTAINMENT OF OUR-
NATIONAL AND STATE. ENTERS THE
SHIFT NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT WE
HAVE THE COMING UP IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR OR OZONE SMOG. AND
IT HAS TO BE AT ALL HANDS ON
DECK FIVE PRIORITY. MOBILE
SOURCES. MANY CASES FEDERAL
SOURCES LIKE WERE STATE SOURCES
LIKE THE TRUCKS SHIPS AND
LOCOMOTIVES ARE A KEY PART OF
THE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE IN THE
SOUTH COAST- WORKING WITH CARD.
IT'S GOING TO BE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT WITH U. S. EPA'S CAN
BE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I'M
SORRY TRANSITION EXCUSE
ACKNOWLEDGE HE EXCUSE ME EXCUSE
ME I WAS WONDERING IF I COULD
INTERRUPT YOU TO HAVE OUR VICE
CHAIR JUST CONNECT WIT- OUR
STENOGRAPHER BECAUSE I SAW THAT
SHE WAS MAKING FACES AND WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT SHE WAS- ABLE
TO TRANSCRIBE YEAH I DIDN'T SEE
THAT ON. ARE YOU ABLE TO GET
OUT BUT IT'S OKAY NOW BUT IT
WAS GOING IN AND OUT SO IT'S
BETTER NOW IT'S BETTER NOW AND
I'M DOING MY BEST SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. YOU MAY CONTINUE
THEM AND THEN- I'M ONLY SIR IF
YOU COULD JUST SPEAK A LITTLE
SLOWER BECAUSE THAT THE
INTERNET IS SPOTTY. AND SHE'S
TRANSCRIBING AS YOU'RE TALKING
SO I THINK THAT MIGHT HELP. YES
APOLOGIES NO WORRIES. IT'S THE
OLD NEW YORKER IN ME. IN ANY
EVENT WE HAVE TO TRANSITION
THESE DIESEL TECHNOLOGIES
MOSTLY IN THE MOBILE SOURCE
SECTOR TO CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES
CARBON IS AN EXTREMELY CRITICAL
PARTNER IN THIS. UPCOMING IS
CARBS MOBILE SOURCE STRATEGY
PART OF THAT IS GOING TO BE
EXAMINING APPROACHES TO ADDRESS
OUR OZONE AND MOBILE SOURCE
ISSUES OF COURSE IN THE SOUTH
COAST AND A KEY PART OF THIS
ALSO IS THE INCENTIVE DOLLARS.
WE ARE GOING TO NEED TO
INCENTIVIZE INDUSTRY
PARTICULARLY SOME OF THE SMALL
BUSINESSES SMALL TRUCKERS FOR
EXAMPLE YOU SHIFT TO THE
INTERTECHNOLOGY ISN'T CAR.
WHETHER IT'S A CAR MORE PROGRAM
VOLKSWAGEN PROGRAM THERE'S- A
LOT OF MONEY POTENTIALLY IN THE
STATE BUDGET THAT IS BEING
NEGOTIATED NOW FOR THE
INCENTIVES. WORKING BETWEEN
SOUTH COAST AND CARP ON THOSE
ISSUES IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
GREAT THANK YOU- AND I DO AGREE
THOSE INCENTIVE DOLLARS ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT THAT THEY GET
DISTRIBUTED IN A WAY- THAT IS
EQUITABLE AND FAIR- ACROSS ALL
PORTIONS OF THE STATE SO THAT
EVERYONE FEELS LIKE THEY ARE
INVESTING IN. THIS NEW KIND OF
ECONOMY- AND INFRASTRUCTURE-
THAT WE HAVE DECIDED THAT WE
WANT TO BECOME MORE RELIANT ON-
YOU KNOW DOCTOR BONUS I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU I THINK IN
SOME OF YOUR RESPONSES YOU SAID
THAT YOU WERE. RE IVIGORATED-
ARE EXCITED ABOUT THIS RE
APPOINTMENT AND REINVIGORATED
BECAUSE OF- THE LEADERSHIP- AND
THE NEW FOLKS THAT ARE JOINING
ON THE BOARD SO I WOULD LOVE IF
YOU COULD SHARE WITH US WHY YOU
HAVE THAT SENSE OF RENEWED
EXCITEMENT. AND WHAT YOU ARE
HOPING- TO HELP ACCOMPLISH-
WITH- THIS NEW BOARD- WITH THIS
NEW TERM. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE I AM. EXCITED
ABOUT- HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH- CHAIR RANDOLPH I
NOW CONFIRMED AND- THE THREE-
OTHER APPOINTEES STATE YOU'RE
HEARING BECAUSE- DUBBED I HAVE
BEEN WORKING THE ENTIRE TIME
THAT I'VE BEEN ON THE BOARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CONSIDER
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND I
REGULATORY ACTIONS. AND I FEEL
LIKE WE MADE PROGRESS AND I
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR PASSING AB SIX ONE SEVEN
BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY MADE IT
POSSIBLE. FOR CARVE TO FOCUS
LIKE AGE IT ALWAYS SHOULD HAVE
ON ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE- IT'S
MADE U WALK THE WALK. AS
OPPOSED TO JUST YOU KNOW TALK
ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
BECAUSE WE NOW HAVE TO WORK
WITH. WE HAVE TO PARTNER WITH
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
LIKE THE SOME OF THE
COMMUNITIES YOU REPRESENT. AND
THAT IT'S PRETTY CLEAR TO ME
THAT- THE GOVERNOR IN
APPOINTING CHAIR RANDOLPH- MIS
HEARD. DR JEKYLL WARNER AND- MR
KRAKOFF AS WELL AS-
REAPPOINTING ME THAT. HE'S
INTERESTED IN SEEING. THE
BOARD- FOCUS ON ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE- TO MAKE SURE THAT-
COMMUNITIES WITH
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF AIR
POLLUTION THAT AFFECTS THEIR
HEALTH- THE TECH GETS RE
DRESSED AS BEST WE CAN. SB SIX
ONE SEVEN IS GONNA SOLVE
EVERYTHING AS I KNOW YOU KNOW
BUT IT'S A STEP FORWARD IN A
PORTENT STEP FORWARD I REALLY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT BE
SUCCESSFUL YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
CONSIDERED A MODEL FOR THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY AND THE WORLD IN
TERMS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
MITIGATION POLICY BUT IF WE CAN
MAKE A BE SIX ONE SEVEN WORK WE
WILL BE A LEADER IN.
IMPLEMENTING A LEGISLATIVE
MANDATE THAT DIRECTS THE AGENCY
TO. DEAL WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICE SO THAT'S WHY I'M
REINVIGORATED I REALLY FEEL
THAT- WHERE. THE GOVERNOR AND
HOPEFULLY THE LEGISLATURE WANTS
US TO GO IS IN MY WHEEL HOUSE-
AND I REALLY. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE- CURRENT BOARD
MEMBERS ALREADY APPOINTED- AND
THEN. HOPEFULLY OF MY FELLOW.
NEW APPOINTEES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THEN I JUST HAVE ONE
LAST QUESTION VICE CHAIR REALLY
DIRECTED TO- THESE AMAZING
WOMEN MISS HURT AND DOCTOR OF
PAYCHECK- WEREN'T LEARNER- WHO
BOTH ACTUALLY TALKED ABOUT.
YOUR LIVED EXPERIENCES- AND
COMING FROM PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES- AND USING THAT
LANDS AT TO HELP INFORM ALL OF
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE BEEN
DOING- AND PROBABLY WILL HELP
INFORM YOUR WORK AS A BOARD
MEMBER. ON CAR. YOU KNOW- THERE
WERE SOME ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
GROUPS AND OTHERS WHO PUBLICLY
RESIGNED THEIR APPOINTMENTS- TO
SHOW THEIR DISPLEASURE. WITH
THE LACK OF ATTENTION THAT THE
PAST A OR B. I. HAU TO-
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE THIRTY S.
SENATE DISTRICT- AND YET WE
KNOW THAT WE CANNOT BLOCK IT
YOU KNOW ISSUES RIGHT. THE
BLACK EMISSIONS- ED METHANE-
YOU KNOW BUILDING TOXICITY- A
LACK OF CLEAN WATER- A LACK OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE YOU KNOW
THOSE THINGS IMPACT RURAL
COMMUNITIES THEY ALSO IMPACT
URBAN COMMUNITIES PROBABLY IN
DIFFERENT WAYS. SO WANTED TO
KNOW IF THE TWO OF YOU ALL
COULD JUST SORT OF SHARE OF THE
KINDS OF ASSURANCES YOU CAN
GIVE THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
SENATE- THAT IF CONFIRMED YOU
AND YOUR FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS
AND YOU ALL MAYBE LEADING THEM.
IN IN IN SOME WAYS- WILL BE
RESPONSIVE TO OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN DRIVE POLICY
OUTCOMES AFTER ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- TO HELP
DRIVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND
POLICIES RATHER THAN KIND OF TO
DEFER TO STAFF BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT SOMETIMES THAT HAPPENS-
AND- BUT YOUR VOICE IS WILL BE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. I'M AND I
THINK THEY WILL BE IMPORTANT IN
LEADING- DISCUSSIONS AROUND
POLICY- AND IN IN FIGURING OUT
WAYS TO PARTNER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE SO WOULD LOVE TO
HEAR ABOUT YOUR RESPONSE TO
THAT. LET ME OF MISS HER TO FEW
WOULD GO FIRST I THOUGHT THE
DOCTOR PACHECO WARNER YOU ARE
MUTE SO- WE'LL GO WITH OF HIS
HURT FIRST AND THEN. YOU CAN
FOLLOW. S. THANK YOU SAID- FOR
THAT QUESTION AND JOHN. IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO LIST ALL VOICES AND I
HAVE TO TELL YOU I WAS
DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR THAT SOME
PEOPLE DID RESIDENTS OF.
RESIGNED FROM THE PROCESS
ESPECIALLY AS- A FORMER MAYOR
AND CURRENT COUNCIL MEMBER YOU
WANT EVERYBODY TO BE INVESTED
IN THE PROCESS AND FEEL LIKE
THEIR INPUT. IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE OUR TIME IS VERY
VALUABLE AND I JUST WANTED TO-
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE PEOPLE
AND ALL THESE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
I'M OPEN TO ALL THE POLICIES
AND IDEAS AND THOUGHTS AND
WANTING TO DO WHAT'S BEST FOR
CALIFORNIA MEANS THE
INTEGRATION OF ALL THE STOCKS
IT MEANS. EVERYONE CITY YEAH TO
TABLE AND EXPRESSING WHAT THEY
THINK IS GOOD FOR THE
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO WHAT'S
GOOD FOR THE OUTCOME- OF. THE
ENTIRE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO I
CITY MY LIVED EXPERIENCES ARE
IMPORTANT- BECAUSE I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK THE LANGUAGE OF
ALL COMMUNITIES- AND I THINK
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN SOMETHING.
AND THAT MAY HAVE BEEN MISSING
BEFORE AND SOMETHING THAT I
WISH TO BRING- AS I SAID AS A
BOARD MEMBER- EIGHT WE'VE GOT A
LOT OF. GOALS THAT WE NEED TO
REACH AND WE CAN'T DO IT ON OUR
OWN WE HAVE MANY DIFFERENT
SISTER. AGENCIES THAT NEED TO
SPEAK TOGETHER WE HAVE MANY
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES SOME
IMPACTED GREATER THAN OTHERS.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
ARE CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE TO.
MOVE TOGETHER AND LISTEN AND
LEARN AND THEN IMPLEMENT- AND
EMPLOY- EVERYONE'S GREAT
THOUGHTS- AT THE END OF THE DAY
TO THE TABLE- SO AGAIN I I'M
TRULY COMMITTED. TO PROMOTE
THOSE VOICES. VOICES FOCUSED ON
HELPS HAVE VOICES ARE FOCUSED
ON ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS- SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
FOR CALIFORNIA AND TO CONTINUE
REDUCING. EMISSIONS THAT AREN'T
SO. THANK YOU DR PROJECT WARNER
OUGHT TO GO NEXT. YEAH I THINK
THEY- JUST AS FOR ME I'M
THINKING ABOUT HOW MY
EXPERIENCE AND MY IDENTITY-
FRIENDS A LOT OF MY WORK I ALSO
KNOW THEY- THE VOICE OF THEM IN
MY MENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY IS
SO IMPORTANT TO THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAVE
BECAUSE THEY DO TALK TO
RESIDENTS THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. BY
OUR RULE MAKING OR LACK OF WILL
MAKE IN IN SOME AREAS AND I
THINK FOR ME I'M COMING FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE
COMING FROM HEALTH EQUITY-
PERSPECTIVE I ALWAYS THINK
ABOUT NEEDING TO BE AS CLEAR AS
OPEN AND AS- I. CLEAR AS
POSSIBLE WHEN IT COMES TO IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT WHO
REALLY NEEDS TO BE AT THE TABLE
HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT THE
VOICES THAT NEED TO- HAVE AND
REALLY HOW WILL THE DECISION
MAKING WORK AND I THINK THAT.
WHEN IT CAME TO WHEN I READ THE
LETTERS OF THOSE THAT I HAD
RESIGNED FROM. THAT COMMITTEE-
WHAT I REALLY TOOK FROM THAT
IS- HOW CAN WE DO THINGS BETTER
FROM THE GET GO SO THAT.
EXPECTATIONS ARE RIGHT SO THAT
WE'RE CLEAR ON WHAT WE'RE
ASKING- PEOPLE- THAT ARE
DONATED TIME TO DO AND THEN
ALSO HOW CAN I AS A BOARD
MEMBER REALLY ELEVATE THOSE
VOICES AND THOSE CONCERNS AS
WELL- TO THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. I DO THINK ABOUT- EVEN
NOW AS I AM. IN MY IN MY ROLE
ALREADY AS FOR NUMBER AND- IN
THE SELECTION OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE FAR SCOPING PLAN-
REALLY POINTING OUT TO STAFF
AND THINGS THAT THEY'VE
ACTUALLY TAKEN ARE TAKING
ACTION ON IN TERMS OF
INCREASING- CERTAIN VOICES AT
THE TABLE BECAUSE AGAIN. I IF I
HEAR THAT FOR EXAMPLE THERE IS
NOT ENOUGH AFRICAN AMERICAN
REPRESENTATION IN OUR DECISION
MAKING PROCESS I DON'T SEE
ENOUGH AFRICAN AMERICAN
REPRESENTATION WHEN IT COMES TO
OUR ADVISORY COMMITTEE I'M
GOING TO SAY SOMETHING. BECAUSE
IT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY FOR MY
HEALTH EQUITY PERSPECTIVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE RIGHT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
VOICES MAKE IT TO THE TABLE
AND- FOR ME TO HELP ELEVATE.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH I ACTS
WANT TO POWER- TO- THE
HONORABLE HURT BECAUSE I DID
NOT ADDRESS MY QUESTION TO YOU
USING YOUR TITLE. AND I. THAT
IS SOMETHING YOU KNOW SO
APOLOGIES TO THAT AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU ALL- FOR YOUR
TIME AND JUST REQUEST THAT YOU
ALL USE YOUR POWER. AS BOARD
MEMBERS- IF YOU ARE CONFIRMED
BECAUSE IT IS AN INCREDIBLE
ONE- AND IT IS ONE THAT WE
SHOULD BE LISTENING TO- NINO
THERE'S A REASON WHY YOU ALL
WERE SELECTED SO I JUST.
IMPLORE YOU OUGHT TO CONSIDER
THAT AND THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR
ME. THEN THE- SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND TAKING OUR QUESTIONS
AND I DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
TO- TO ASK RIGHT I FIRST WANT
TO START IF AT ALL POSSIBLE-
AND I DON'T PARTICULARLY HAVE A
PREFERENCE OF WHO RESPONDS TO
THIS QUESTION. I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM BOTH- THE HONORABLE
HURT AND THEN ALSO THE ON A
PARTICULAR WARNER- OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE OF THE EXPERIENCES THE
LIVED EXPERIENCES THAT THEY
HAVE AND I DO APPRECIATE THAT-
THE ENVELOPE AND CHECK A WARNER
IS FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY. I
DO APPRECIATE THAT- SHE GREW UP
IN THE VALLEY SHE LIVES IN THE
VALLEY AND SHE UNDERSTANDS THE
IMPACTS OF AGRICULTURE- AND OIL
IN THE VALLEY. I ALSO WANT TO
COMPLIMENT- SO YOUR BEST FRIEND
AND WE WILL KEEP THE PEDAL IN
THE END ONLY CHILL AFN- YOU
LAUNCH THE AND THE- INTO MY
MOTHER HE SAID HE COULD NO I
JUST WANT TO BE BOTH THE AUTO
BONTA GILAD TODAY BEEN A TOTAL
AND THEN IF I SAID THAT RATE
WHICH I MAY HAVE YOU MAY NOT
HAVE IT SAYS THAT- YOUR MOM
TOLD YOU ONE TIME- ESPECIALLY
GO WONDER THAT YOU'RE NOT A
GOLD COIN. SO NOT EVERYBODY'S
GOING TO LIKE YOU. I IS OUT OF
RIGHT. YES YEAH YOU GOT IT
RIGHT ON. AND YOU KNOW THAT'S
WHAT I APPRECIATE ABOUT YOU
VERY MUCH THIS IS THE SECOND
TIME I'VE HAD YOU BEFORE ME
AND- I KNOW THAT WE SPENT TIME
IN MY OFFICE ON SEVERAL
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD- AND I
APPRECIATE IT I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT NOT EVERYBODY'S GOING
TO LIKE WHAT YOU DO TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN STILL PRODUCE
FOOD IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY FOR
CONSTITUENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT NOT
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO LIKE THE
FACT THAT AND OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE THAT ADVERSELY AFFECT OR
THAT MAKE FARMERS OR GROWERS
RANCHERS DO ADDITIONAL THINGS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
CLEANER AIR QUALITY- AND IT AND
I APPRECIATE THAT SO WHICH
MAKES ME THINK THAT YOU ARE
JUST GOING TO BE A WONDERFUL
WELL BALANCED- PERSON ON THIS
BOARD WITH NO ACTIVIST
BACKGROUND- SO I DO WANT TO
APPRECIATE THAT. I DO- I DO
HAVE A COMMENT- THERE WAS A- A
FRESNO STATE RESEARCH
SCIENTIST. SAID BASED ON THE
ONLY VALLEY RAP- IT CAN YOU
CLARIFY STATEMENT THAT YOU MADE
IN THE SAN THE STATEMENT WAS
RIGHT NOW I'M GOING TO BE A
LEARNER AND A LISTENER BUT
CHECK A WARNER SAID. I THINK
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO
FURTHER INCENTIVIZE IMPORTANT
NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT COULD
BENEFIT OUR VALLEY'S ECONOMY
AND- OUR AIR SUCH AS ZERO
EMISSIONS TRANSPORTATION. YEAH
CAN YOU TELL ME HOW YOU THINK
THAT THAT BRINGING BALANCE TO
THAT SITUATION IS GOING TO HELP
ALL SIDES OF THE ECONOMY
ESPECIALLY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. THANK YOU. I THINK
THEY- WHEN WE THINK ABOUT- THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE THAT KEEPS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AT NINETEEN
THAT- WHEN IT COMES TO ITS AIR
QUALITY GOALS IT IS MOBILE
SOURCE POLLUTION AND SO FOR ME
GETTING TO THAT PLACE OF NOT
ONLY A TEAM MATCH REALLY SEEN
THE BENEFIT FOR ALL OF LAST AND
LIVING IN THE VALLEY TAPPED IN
YOUR AIR DOES INCLUDE TACKLING
THE MOBILE SOURCE POLLUTION.
ARE PART OF THAT EQUATION I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT IN TERMS OF OUR
ECONOMY- EIGHT THE OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION IS VERY IMPORTANT
AND- NOT ONLY- AS AN INDUSTRY
BUT I THINK ABOUT THE PEOPLE-
AND I KNOW THAT THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE VERY SMALL- OF
THAT BUSINESS OWNERS THAT ARE
HEAVILY IMPACTED BY THE
DECISIONS MAKE THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSIONS-
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
REALLY HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT. WHAT IS TRANSITION LOOK
LIKE AND- AND HOW DO WE HOW DO
WE FRAME IT IN A WAY THAT WE'RE
ALSO THINKING ABOUT HOW WE NOT
ONLY TRANSITION BACK ON PART OF
OUR ECONOMY BUT ALSO WITH THE
RECOGNITION. THAT- I YOU SAID-
CENTER GROVE YOU KNOW I HAVE
VERY THE- I TOO DON'T DON'T
WANT TO STAY- ALARM IMPORT OF
THE BOY AND GAS WHEN WE CAN BE.
IT HERE I THINK WE- THOSE NEED
TO BE PART THE VERY DIFFICULT.
CONVERSATION THAT I AM ASK. AND
IN. JUSTICE WHEN I WITH THEM
I'M ASKING OF OUR STAFF AND AS-
YOU WILL COMES TO AS- IN TERMS
OF OVER IS YOU KNOW WHAT THE
REAL. FRIEND OF THE TRANSIT
FIRST. ANOTHER TREND- AND SO DO
THAT THAT CARE COULD. IS NEEDED.
I DO I CAN'T SAY I HAVE THE AND
IN TERMS OF THE FORMULA OF THE-
BUT I JUST KNOW THE QUESTION
NEED TO BE ASK THAT EVERY.
POINT OF WAY AND TRY OF ANY
TYPE OF ROOM. THAT WOULD THAT
IS. OUR ARE MORE ON ECONOMY AS
YOU IMAGE VEHICLE IKANA- WHILE-
IN MIND. WHAT EFFECT IT HOW ON
OUR- FOLKS ON THE GROUND- IN
THIS VALLEY THAT I HOW THE
RECORDS. DETER MISUNDERSTOOD.
AND WHERE TACTICS TO BE
PRODUCED TOO MUCH OIL BUT WE
DON'T PRODUCE THE OIL YOU'RE
GONNA IMPORTED FROM ANOTHER
COUNTRY- WERE ATTACKED BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW THE PREDOMINATELY
THING FOR A WHITE POPULATION WE
HAVE 70% LATINO THE OIL
INDUSTRY EMPLOYEES. A SECOND
CHANTERS UNITED STATES MILITARY
VETERANS- YOU KNOW 61% OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR. 35% OF SECOND
CHANCES PEOPLE ON THE PA HIGH
SCHOOL THE FULSOME PIPELINE AND
THEN THEY GET A JOB IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY BECAUSE THEIR PAROLE
OFFICER FROM LOS ANGELES AND-
YOU KNOW GO THERE. AND YOU KNOW
THEY MAKE YOU KNOW EIGHTY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
WHICH IS REALLY GOOD THEY BUY
HOMES THEY BUY CARS. AND SO I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU. AND AGAIN
WITH THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
PRODUCING THE FOOD. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE A
MEMBER OF THIS BOARD AND I'VE
BEEN IN THIS BUILDING FOR
ALMOST TWELVE YEARS- AND YOU
ARE REALLY ONE OF THE VERY
FIRST PEOPLE THAT I'VE COME
ACROSS THAT TAKES A REASONABLE.
AT LEAST A LISTENING APPROACH
AND TAKES INTO A AFFECT THE
ECONOMIC VITALITY- THAT GREATLY
IMPACTS OUR ENVIRONMENT TO- YOU
KNOW. HOW TO THE POOR FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. I HAD A
PEOPLE THAT TRAVEL SIXTY FIVE
MILES A DAY BOTH WAYS IN THE
FARMING COMMUNITY GOING ONE
PLACE THE VALUE THE OTHER. GET
THERE WITHOUT DRIVING A GAS
VEHICLE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE. AND
ANGELINI I I'M BORN AND RAISED
ARVINDER REASON BAKERSFIELD I
OTHER THAN THE TIME I SERVED
OVERSEAS IN THE MILITARY. I'VE
BEEN IN THIS COMMUNITY MY
ENTIRE LIFE AND- I DON'T SEE A
LOT OF TESLA'S IN MY AREA. AND
SO I JUST APPLAUD YOU. FOR A-
YOU KNOW TAKING THAT STANCE TO
AT LEAST LISTENING TO THAT
COMMUNITY SO THANK YOU MA'AM
VERY MUCH FULFILL A MY NEXT
QUESTION IS- WITH. JUST A
MINUTE I'M SORRY I LOST MY
PLACE LIKE. HERE DID WELL BACK
OKAY. THE TO DEFY THE HONORABLE
DIRECTOR HURT. AM I HAD A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS ON HIGH
SPEED RAIL THAT I WANTED TO ASK
AND IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME BASED
ON THIS YOU ARE THE EXPERT ON
HIGH SPEED RAIL. M. I KNOW YOUR
HIGH SPEED RAIL ADVOCATE AND
YOU. THE DID THE BELMONT HIGH
SPEED RAIL COMMITTEE SO YOU
OBVIOUSLY HAVE EXPERIENCE ON
THAT SO IF I COULD ASK YOU A
FEW QUESTIONS IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE. I KNOW THERE'S A
STEADY UP THE GIVES THE- OUTPUT
IS A- OF EMISSIONS ON THE
PRODUCTION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
IN IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE DONE
WITHIN A CERTAINLY OF TIME. THE
WE'VE EXCEEDED THAT TIME FRAME.
WHAT'S THE ESTIMATE TIME FRAME
WHERE WE WOULD ACTUALLY GET A
NET ZERO FOR CARBON EMISSIONS
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL AND HOW
LONG IS IT GONNA TAKE US TO
MAKE UP THE CARBON EMISSIONS
FOR THE BUILDING PROJECT. THANK
YOU SENATOR FORD CAN'T QUESTION
I SHOULD SAY THAT I WAS A HIGH
SPEED RAIL ADVOCATE MANY MANY
YEARS AGO. WHEN I FIRST
STARTED- AND THERE'S BEEN MUCH
CHANGE. SINCE THEN AS AS IT
RELATES TO- HOW THAT'S EVOLVED
IN EVEN IN MY OWN COMMUNITY.
WHERE THE LOCATION IS OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL AND HOW THAT
INTERACTION EFFECTS. AS IT
RELATES- JUNTS TO THE
COMMUNITIES. SO WHAT I AM AND
WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT- I
RESPECT- MASS TRANSPORTATION
AND ITS IMPORTANCE. AS SOMEONE
HAD SPIES SAID EARLIER. TODAY
BUT TRANSPORTATION IS ONE OF
OUR LARGEST- EMISSION
REDUCTIONS BASIS WE NEED TO OUR
FAX. AND YOU KNOW THERE IS A
SLIGHT TENSION WITH. VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED AS WELL AS
GETTING PEOPLE ON PUBLIC
TRANSIT. AND SO- I AM LOOKING
FOR THE LATEST TECHNOLOGY AND
TRYING TO FIND AND FIGURE OUT
WAYS THAT WE CAN REDUCE PEOPLE
DRIVING- BY THEMSELVES AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. AND TRYING TO USE.
NOT ONLY HIGH SPEED RAIL- BUT
ALSO IN OUR- AREA CALTRAIN-
THEY WERE GOING TO ELECTRIFY-
AND SO IT'S INVESTMENTS I
SEATED FOR THE FUTURE AND-
THEY'RE NOT. EASY- IT'S NOT AS
SOME. OUT SAY THAT MY BUT I BUT
I WILL SAY HIGH SPEED RAIL IS
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE- MOBILE
SOURCES THAT GETTING TO-
MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE- IN LARGER.
GROUPS SO THAT WE CAN REDUCE
EMISSIONS AND I'M FOLLOWING IT
CLOSELY- AND I HAVE MY EYES TO
FIGURING OUT- JUST EXACTLY HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. FOR CALIFORNIA
AND IT IT WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR
ME TO WATCH HOW IT ALSO IMPACTS
THE COMMUNITIES FOR WHAT SHE
GOES THROUGH. SO IT I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT AGAIN WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT LIVED
EXPERIENCES I MEAN I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY EXCEPT FOR MR
TRISH WARNER'S GROWN UP IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. NO ONE IS GOING
TO BRING KERN- THIS IS TAKE
RIDGECREST IN TWO AND A HALF
HOURS EAST OF BAKERSFIELD WHICH
IS A CENTRAL PART OF IT THAT
DISTRICT. AND THERE'S NO RAIL
THAT GOES FROM RIDGECREST
BAKERSFIELD. IT'S A TWO AND A
HALF HOUR DRIVE AND- IF YOU ARE.
SEVERELY INJURED IN THE EAST
PART OF THE COMMUNITY THE
CLOSEST HOSPITAL I GUESS
RICHEST ME TO PATCH BE BUT BE
GOING OVER MOUNTAIN PASSES BUT
TO GET TO BAKERSFIELD. M. THEY
STABILIZE YOU AND THEN
TRANSPORTED BY AMBULANCE OR-
STABILIZE YOU ENOUGH TO GET YOU
IN A PERSONAL CAR AND THEN THEY
LET YOU TRY TO BAKERSFIELD FOR
TREATMENT. I JUST THINK THAT
AND YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO GO FROM LOS
ANGELES TO SAN FRANCISCO OR LOS
ANGELES PRESS TO SACRAMENTO.
BUT I JUST DON'T SEE HOW YOU
GET IN OUR COMMUNITY M. F.
TULARE- AND KERN FRESNO I THINK
COULD MANAGE. BUT M. THE
MOUNTAIN COMMUNITIES DEFINITELY
CAN AND I JUST THINK THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE CONSIDERATION FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT- ARE GOING TO
DRIVE I MEAN THEY'RE GOING TO
DRIVE LIKE I SAID YOU KNOW I
HAVE A COLLEAGUE THAT YOU KNOW
REPRESENTS TWENTY SIX BLOCKS OF
THE- YOU KNOW SAVE A LOS
ANGELES YOU CAN WALK THAT
DISTRICT. AS A MATTER OF FACT
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY THE
PERSON WHO REPRESENT THAT
DISTRICT I WAS IN A FIGHT WITH
ONE OF MY KIDS I FIVE KIDS-
MIGHT. DAUGHTER HAD WRECKED HER
CAR. AND I'M ON THE PHONE
BECAUSE I TOOK THE TRAIN AT.
AND SHE'S THE- THE- I TO THE
TRAIN THE REGULAR TRAIN
OBVIOUSLY- ANYWAYS- SO I'M
ARGUING WITH HER AND I'M LIKE
DON'T YOU TOUCH MY CAR AND
SHE'S WRECKED HER CAR SHE'S NOT
DRIVING MY CAR. IN SO IDEA IT
WAS ON THE PHONE ARGUE WITH HER
AND THAT COLLEAGUE OF MINE IN
THE ASSEMBLY GOES I CAN'T
BELIEVE YOU HAVE A TWO CAR
FAMILY. AND I THOUGHT FOR A
SECOND I'M LIKE. GOSH WE'RE A
SEVEN CAR FAMILY. FIVE KIDS ME
MY HUSBAND PLUS WE HAVE A RANCH
TRUCK THAT WE TAKE TO THE RANCH.
IN AND THE COMMENT THAT SHE
REPLIED BACK TO ME IS LIKE YOUR
FAMILY IS THE TOTAL BECAUSE OF
GLOBAL WARMING. AND I JUST
THOUGHT WELL YOU HAVE NO IDEA I
THE KID THAT TRIES TO FROM
BAKERSFIELD FRESNO STATE TO GO
TO SCHOOL AND GET AN EDUCATION.
I HAVE A DAUGHTER THAT TRIES TO
BAKERSFIELD TO GO BE A NURSE TO
HELP PEOPLE. AND GET WELL AND
BE BETTER. I HAVE ANOTHER
DAUGHTER THAT DRIVES TO- TAFT
TO GET HER OLDER STANDARDS
CALLED IMAGING ENGINEER NOW.
AND CERTIFICATE OR WHATEVER SO
THAT SHE CAN DO ALTER SOUNDS
AND MY HUSBAND GOES TO WORK AND
I GO TO WORK AND THERE'S NO WAY
WE COULD SHARE. A COUPLE OF
VEHICLES. AND SO I JUST THINK
THAT THE LIVED EXPERIENCES THAT
WE ALL HAVE HAVE IN WILL MAKE
DECISIONS IN THIS BUILDING
BASED ON OUR LIFE EXPERIENCE I
GET THAT. I GET THAT NO ONE
KNOWS HOW WE LIVE- UNTIL THEY
EXPERIENCE IT AND YOU KNOW I
DON'T KNOW HOW MY COLLEAGUE IN.
YOU KNOW LOS ANGELES HERE THIS
IT'S NEXT TO ME. WHAT HER
LIFESTYLE IS BUT I KNOW IT'S
DIFFERENT THAN MINE. BUT I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THOSE LIFE
EXPERIENCES WHERE THEY ARE. AND
I WOULD JUST LIKE SOME. A
LITTLE CONSIDERATION I GUESS
FOR THE VALLEY. IN EVERYTHING
THAT WE HAVE TO OFFER THIS
STATE- AGAIN I KNOW THAT YOU
GUYS ARE SO ARE- YOU HAVE A
SEVERE IMPACT ON THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY. WHERE
THE SECOND TOP PRODUCING FRESNO
IS THE FIRST. CURRENTS A SECOND
A TWITTER IS A THIRD FOOD
PRODUCING COUNTY IN THE WORLD.
I BELIEVE WE PRODUCE OVER A
HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
COMMODITIES WHERE WE PRODUCE
99% OF THAT FOOD SUPPLY. FOR
THE WORLD. AND YOU KNOW PUTTING
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AT A
BUSINESS FROM GROWING FOOD NOT
ONLY AFFECTS THE FOOD SUPPLY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT THE
FOOD SUPPLY FOR THE WORLD AND
THAT IS NOT AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
THE GOVERNOR OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS BLESSED. TO
GOVERNOR STATE WITH THE TOP SIX
PRODUCING. FOOD COUNTIES IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD SALINAS VALLEY
WHERE THEY GROW THE LETTUCE AND
THINGS LIKE THAT SO IT'S NOT
JUST A CENTRAL VALLEY. AND I
JUST THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME TYPE OF CONSIDERATION FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES. THAT ARE
TRYING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
AND WE ARE POLITICALLY
DIFFERENT. M. BUT WE ARE TRYING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP MEET
THE CLIMATE GOALS THAT ARE SET
FORTH. LIKE I SAID EARLIER 51%
OF THE SOLAR. THAT FUELS
CALIFORNIA COMES FROM KERN
COUNTY. AND THOSE MEGA SOLAR
WHAT PLANTS ARE IN KERN COUNTY
AND WE GET NO BENEFIT. THE
ENERGY GOES NORTH AND GO SOUTH
AND WE DON'T GET TAX REVENUE.
M. AND IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING.
SO I JUST AM LOOKING FOR
SOMEBODY HE WILL JUST TAKE AN
HONEST LOOK LIKE. LIKE MISS
WATER I'D PICK A WINNER I DON'T
I DON'T THINK SHE'LL AGREE WITH
US 1100% OF THE TIME SHE MAY
NOT EVEN AGREE WITH US 50% OF
THE TIME. BUT SHE'S WILLING. TO
LOOK AT THIS SIDE JUST LIKE I'M
SURE SHE'S WILLING TO LOOK AT
LOS ANGELES ASIDE. AND THAT'S
ALL I'M ASKING FOR IS SOMEBODY
WHO'S GONNA LOOK AT THINGS.
FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE SPECTRUM
AND NOT BE AN ACTIVIST ON THE
BOARD NOT THAT YOU ARE I DON'T
MEAN IT LIKE THAT I'M JUST
LOOKING THAT'S THE BOARD MEMBER
I'M LOOKING FOR. AND SO- I
APPRECIATE YOU GIVING ME THAT
INFORMATION THAT- YOU
APPRECIATE MASS PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. BUT I ALSO WANT
YOU TO APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
IT ALWAYS DOESN'T WORK IN EVERY
AREA OF THE STATE. AND I'M I'M
SMILING. I KNOW YOU CAN'T SEE
THE- I AGREE WITH YOU AND I
THINK JUST TO. MAYBE MAKE ONE
MORE COMMENT TO THIS POINT NO
ONE SIZE FITS ALL DOESN'T WORK-
AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT
CENTRAL VALLEY IS MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN THE BAY AREA
AND- AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT I'M LEARNING AND LISTENING
AND UNDERSTANDING EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'RE SAYING RIGHT NOW
AND WILL INTEGRATE THAT INTO MY
DECISIONS AS IT RELATES TO ALL
OF CALIFORNIA- SO I HEAR YOU HI
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT AND I
WILL TAKE THOSE THINGS INTO
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MA'AM
N. F. I HAVE TO APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR I MEAN GO GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM I MEAN THE MAKE UP
OF THIS BOARD WITH WOMEN IS-
VERY. IT'S PRETTY AWESOME SO
I'M A SO THANK YOU FOR THAT. I
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
ARE KIND OF JUST SMALL
QUESTIONS AND- FOR DIRECTOR-
KRAKOFF. THEY SAY THAT RIGHT.
NOW YES. AND I NOTICED YOU'RE A
LAWYER FROM LA- YOU'RE A LAWYER
FROM LA- BUT I SEE THAT YOU'RE
KIND OF TIED TO THE RECYCLING
INDUSTRY CAN YOU TELL ME HOW
THAT HOW. THAT THAT IS. JUST
CURIOUS. I'M JUST CURIOUS. YES
CENTER GROWTH. I AS THE COUNCIL
FOR A TRADE ASSOCIATION OF
SOLID WASTE RECYCLERS AND
HOLLERS FOR ABOUT SIXTEEN YEARS.
HATCHET GIVE THAT JOB UP TO
AVOID CONFLICTS WITH CAR. THEY
WERE VERY HEAVILY REGULATED
THERE SOMEBODY'S THERE ARE
TRUCKS THE AMOUNT OF WASTE THAT
THEY RECYCLE- AND SORT OF LIKE
CONFLICTS HAD TO GIVE UP THAT
REALLY WONDERFUL RELATIONSHIP
AND TO TAKE THE CAR BACK TO THE
CAR GETTING PERCENT SIXTEEN
YEARS DOING THAT. MEMBERS OF
FORTUNE FIFTY COMPANIES ALL THE
WAY TOO SMALL BUSINESSES FAMILY
OWNED BUSINESSES. WITH TWO OR
THREE TRUCKS. AM I APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK I DO AGREE WITH
YOU I APPLAUD YOU FOR BEING AN
ATTORNEY TO HELP THE RECYCLING
INDUSTRY AGAIN. IT'S A GOAL
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS TO YOU KNOW GO 21100%
RECYCLING ZERO LANDFILL- BUT
THIS INDUSTRY. THE IS I MEAN I
THINK. GET A HIGHLY REGULATED
IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT I THINK
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL AND THE
STATE THEY HAVE A HUNDRED FORTY
ONE AGENCIES MOST OF THEM
OVERLAP THAT THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ANSWERING TO.
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO- TO
FUNCTION IN THE STATE EVEN THAT
WE DESPERATELY NEED THEM TOO
SO. I APPRECIATE THAT- RESPONSE
I JUST WANTED TO KNOW WHERE YOU
KIND OF WERE ON THAT I WASN'T
SURE ABOUT THE CONNECTION BUT I
KNEW YOU WERE. SOMEHOW
CONNECTED SO THANK YOU SIR I
THINK YOU ALSO BRING A WELL
BALANCED APPROACH. AND TO PASS
THE BOARD. I DON'T I DON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS AS- MISTER
BELL MAYES UNLESS YOU WANT ME
TO ASK YOU A QUESTION. WELL I
APPRECIATE YOU. SAYING A
PRONOUNCING MY PRONOUNCING MY
NAME THE PROPER CUDDLE ON WAYS
TO CUT A LINE IN THE- SAND
ANGLICISED BOMBS BUT IT'S
REALLY BONUS THANK YOU YEAH
PHARMACIA. OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL
AND- I DON'T HAVE AND- I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOU BUT
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO ME
FOR THE LAST THIRTY MINUTES
AND- I LOOK FORWARD TO. YEAH
BECAUSE BEING ON THE BOARD.
SENATOR GROWTH COULD I SAY ONE
THING ABSOLUTELY SIR. I'VE BEEN
DOING RESEARCH. FIND YOUR
LUCIAN IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY FOR. TWENTY YEARS NOW
AND- YOU KNOW WHILE I'M TRYING
TO LEARN ABOUT HEALTH EFFECTS
OF AIR POLLUTION I'VE ALSO
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THE ECONOMY
OF. THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY ARE
BOTH FRESNO AND KERN COUNTY- SO
I ALSO LIKE- DONNARUMMA MIS
HEARD HEARD YOU AND I ALSO
PLEDGE TO KEEP AN OPEN MIND- I
THINK. OUR WHEN SATURDAY
DUTTON- QUESTION ME WHEN MY
WHEN I WAS RECENTLY APPOINTED
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT HE ASKED
ME ABOUT BALANCE- AND I SAID
YES I'M A PROPONENT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE BUT I
ALSO DON'T TO BREAK THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY- SO I
UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM. I APPRECIATE THAT AND I'M
NOT I MEAN THE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. S. THEY'RE
DEVELOPING TECHNOLOGY ALL THE
TIME I MEAN THEM. YOU KNOW THE
OIL INDUSTRY WENT FRIEND YOU
KNOW GASOLINE GENERATORS TO
SOLAR POWERED ELECTRICITY TO
RUN I MEAN YOU KNOW THE
EVERYBODY'S TRYING TO DO THEIR
PART- BUT I APPRECIATE THAT
COMMENT VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR. WE WILL GO TO SENATOR
LARRY. FOUR K. DE ESTO YOU ON
OUR RETAIL YOLO SAY K. PORTAL
PASAR MENSA HE'S PROVIDE US ARE
LESS THAN A DOLLAR A DAY
BAKERSFIELD IN FRONT THE TOLD.
RENDEL OF COURSE IN THE WAY THE
KIND THAT THE. AND I JUST DID A
DANGEROUS THING IN. FRONT OF
SOMEBODY THAT AS CATALON
ANCESTRY. WE'RE REALLY HAVING A
LOT OF FUN AND THE HEARING
TODAY HEY I HAD A BETTER
ACCENT. HEY I HAVE A WEST
BAKERSFIELD BACKS SO THAT'S THE
ISSUE. I THINK THE THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE DONEA GREAT
JOB OF DRAWING OUT THIS AND
ASKING ACTUALLY MANY OF THE
THINGS I WAS GOING TO SO MAYBE
I'LL DO SOMETHING UNUSUAL WHICH
IS THAT. UNMATCHED WITH THE FOR
MEMBERS AND WE HAVE SINCE IN
THE BRIEF TIME I'VE BEEN ON THE
RULES COMMITTEE WE'VE ALREADY
HAD CONFIRMATION HEARINGS FOR
TO VIEW. OF FOR THE LOCAL
AIRPORT THE HAND UP ANDHAD
RIGOROUS DISCUSSIONS AND
QUESTIONS WHEN THAT HAPPENED
AND SO. WHAT ME JUST SAY THAT.
WE'RE VERY SATISFIED WITH THE
DISCUSSION THAT HAPPENED VERY
SATISFIED WITH THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE HAD. AND I THINK WITH
EACH OF YOU WHEN N. ACTUALLY.
MISTER KRAKOFF WAS- A MEMBER OF
THE MINING AND GEOLOGY BOARD
WHEN I WAS SECRETARY FOR
NATURAL RESOURCES AND I THINK
HE WAS A LEADER IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PART OF THE STATE
BAR. R. AS WELL AND- AND HE
INDICATED IN THE DISCUSSION
THAT HE REPRESENTED
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS
HIS FELLOW AS WELL AS THE TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS AND OTHER SICK
CAME UP PREVIOUSLY IN THE
HEARING. AND I THINK MS BUT
CHECK OR WARNER. ARE REALLY
TALK MEANINGFULLY ABOUT A KID
THAT HAS ASTHMA AND RUN
BACKGROUND TO GROWING
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH
EVERYBODY THAT I THINK WAS
RECOGNIZED. BY CENTER GROVE. A
N. R. I THINK THE MAY. OR SAID
THAT- A MEMBER BOMBINGS DONE.
AND HIS COMMITMENT TO A. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN AT AND WORKING ON
THAT THE QUALIFIES HIM. AND I
THINK FOR MEMBER HEARD. HER A
DISCUSSION IN THE MEETING WAS
REALLY ABOUT PEOPLE'S EVERYDAY
LIVES AND REPRESENTING THEM AT
THE BORDER AND UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THEY DID SO I JUST I'D BE
GOOD TO PUT ON THE RECORD THOSE
THINGS FROM THE DISCUSSION
ACKNOWLEDGED THE ANSWERS TO THE
MEMBERS AND SAY. A BARRING
SOMETHING BIZARRE IN ANY
FURTHER- PUBLIC COMMENT A LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORT IN ALL FOUR
AND OUR CONFIRMATION WHEN WE
COME BACK AND VOTE ON THEM
AFTER WE TAKE THE RECESS HERE
SO THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
AND THANKS TO ALL FOR. FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED AND
YOU WOULD THINK THERE'S NOTHING
LEFT TO ASK AND THEN NGUYEN
APPROACH HIM SINCE IN THIS
POSITION SHE SAYS WELL
EVERYTHING'S BEEN ASKED BUT I
DO HAVE ONE. QUICK QUESTION TO
ASK. THE DOCTOR BONUS THEN YOU
KNOW THAT'S THE WAY WITH.
AUTHORITY TO PRONOUNCE YOUR
NAME THEN I HEARD THEM SAY MOMS
LIKE AUTO WELL WE BETTER DO IT
RIGHT. WOULD YOU SERVE THE
LONGEST THAT I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION AFTER OUR INTERVIEW
WITH- THE NEW OTCHERE.
REGARDING STRUCK THE WAY IT'S
STRUCTURED AND THAT HAS TO DO
WITH VODAFONE- PREVIOUS SLIDE I
GUESS THERE WAS A CONCERN
ABOUT. IT BEING VERY CHAIR
CENTERED IN TERMS OF NOT
INVOLVING ON TO A GREATER
DEGREE BOARD MEMBERS AND NOT
FROM OF THE DECISION MAKING OR
AT LEAST THE DISCUSSION WITH
THE PUBLIC. SO I'M GONNA ASK
YOU DOCTOR BOMBS- GIVEN THE
COMPLEX NATURE OF THE BOARD
ISSUES BEFORE YOU WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON EACH BOARD MEMBER
HAVING A STAFF ADVISOR. WHO
COULD ASSIST YOU WITH GETTING
ANSWERS TO YOUR QUESTIONS PRIOR
TO THE MONTHLY MEETINGS
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU PROBABLY
GET. A LOT INDIVIDUAL AND PUT.
ARE AND THAT MIGHT BE WELL I
SHARED OUR THROUGH A COMMITTEE
STRUCTURE RATHER VAN NOW OF YOU
KNOW BEING ON A BOARD AND-
YOU'RE OUT THERE RIGHT IN FRONT
OF THE PUBLIC AND THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF TIME TO SHARE PERHAPS.
OF WHAT YOU LEARNED IN IN WHICH
SHE PROCESSED ARE AND I THINK
STAFF HELPS HAVING SERVED ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS I KNOW
HONORABLE FOR YOU WOULD KNOW-
YOU GET COMMITTEES FOLLOW THAT
ARE PARTICIPATORY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. VERY VERY
HELPFUL- WHEN YOU HAVE TO MAKE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS. FOR WHAT'S
YOUR THOUGHT ON THAT. AND I
DON'T WANT TO YOU SIDE WITH
SOME NEW CHAIR I. YOU I'M NOT
DOING THAT JUST. THOUGHT I WAS
SAY THAT I WELL THE NEW CHIU
STILL OF WE- FOR THE JURY SO
FAR. BECAUSE IT IS VERY
INCLUSIVE- AND- I SEND THAT-
SHE WANTS US TO BE A TEAM. SHE
MADE ME TO- BUT SHE WANTS IN
COURT FROM ALL OF THE SHE SAID
THAT I THINK- EARLIER IN THIS.
AARON AND I FEEL THAT. SO
THAT'S PART OF WHAT JOHN. WHEN
I RESPONDED TO A SENATOR AT
KAMLAGER ABOUT MY FEELING
REINVIGORATED X. THE NEW
LEADERSHIP THAT CHAIR RANDOLPH
BRINGS- I THINK IS GOING TO BE
MORE- CAN BY CONSENSUS- I VERY
MUCH. I ENJOYED WORKING WITH
THE PREVIOUS CHAIR MARY NICHOLS
WHO I GREATLY RESPECT AND I
THINK SHE DID INCREDIBLE
SERVICE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE NATION IN THE
WORLD. BUT BECAUSE SHE WAS SUCH
A WELL ESTABLISHED LEADER IN
THE FIELD- IT DID TEND TO ARE
WE DO TEND TO FALL IN LINE-
MAYBE MORE OFTEN THAN NOT- IN
TERMS OF HER LEADERSHIP WHICH
WAS I THINK USUALLY ON TARGET
BUT I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO- YOU
KNOW A DIFFERENT. APPROACH THAT
I THINK CHAIR RANDALL BRINGS
AND- I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A
STAFF ADVISOR- YOU KNOW. I'M AN
ACADEMIC. YOU KNOW I HAVEN'T
HAD A SECRETARY ADMINISTRATIVE
ASSISTANT REALLY FOR DECADES I
THINK- DR JEKYLL WARNER
PROBABLY IN A SIMILAR
SITUATION- SO- AND AS FAR AS IS
SORT OF SUBCOMMITTEES- IT'S
ALREADY SORT OF HAPPEN TO SOME
EXTENT- WITH SB SIX ONE SEVEN
AND ALSO WITH THE RESEARCH- THE
OTHER. PRIOR TO- DR JEKYLL
WARNER BEEN APPOINTED TO THE
BOARD THE TWO ACADEMICS DR
SPERLING- THE TRAFFIC ENGINEER
BOARD POSITION AND NEED THE
PHYSICIAN MEMBER WE'RE WE'RE
BOTH ACADEMICS WEEK. NOW ARE
JOINED BY DOCTOR BUT CHECK A
WARNER BUT WE'VE HAD MAJOR
INFLUENCE ON THE RESEARCH
DIRECTION OF THE- OF THE BOARD
WE WERE ASKED TO FORM A LITTLE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO ADDRESS WHAT WE
THOUGHT WERE FOR GAPS IN OUR
RESEARCH- APPROACH AND YOU KNOW
AGAIN LIKE I SAID I WELCOME. DR
JEKYLL WARNER JOINING US IN
THAT- SO. I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
STAFF. ASSISTANCE AND I WOULD I
HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH YOU KNOW
SUB COMMITTEES TO WORK ON
SPECIFIC ISSUES. WELL THANK YOU
FOR THAT RESPONSE I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC
TO HEAR THAT KNOWING THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO BE PART OF THIS
INCLUSIVE PROCESS AND THAT'S
THE WAY IT SHOULD BE AN ALMOST
OF YOU I THINK ALL OF YOU HAVE
REALLY COVERED A LITTLE. OR A
LOT OF THAT IN IN YOUR
COMMENTARY SO THAT IS CERTAINLY
GOOD NEWS ALL OF US WHO
STRUGGLE WHEN WE GET THE
COMPLAINTS FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO BELIEVE THAT
THAT THEIR VOICES WERE NOT
HEARD- I WILL SHARE WITH YOU ON
WHEN I WAS AND I'M BY A MALE
QUALITY THAT WAS BACK IN
TWENTY. FOURTEEN ON THAT
COMMITTEE- ONE OF THE GENTLEMAN
THAT CAME TO TESTIFY AGAINST A
ONE OF THE NEW REGULATIONS BY
CAR BUT ACTUALLY LOVE SONG FROM
ONE OF THE LOW INCOME IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES. AND HE SAID YOU
ARE TAKING AWAY MY LIVELIHOOD
WITH THE OFTEN WHILE I AM VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES IN MY AREA YEAH
HE WAS A DRAFT OF THE VERY
VERY. HE LOOKED LIKE HE JUST
CAME FROM THE JOB BECAUSE HE
HAS WORK CLOTHES ON AND HE WAS
VERY PASSIONATE AND I THOUGHT
MAN WE'VE GOT TO HAVE A LITTLE
MORE UNDERSTANDING A LITTLE
MORE INTERACTIVE. ALL WITH THE
MANNER IN WHICH WE BRING
REGULATIONS FORWARD AND THE
TIMELINE ON THOSE WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE TECHNOLOGY. CATCHING
UP WITH FROM ABOUT. AGAIN WE
THINK INSTEAD OF. OR FORCES
THEM TO MOVE OUR- BUT THE WORD
INCENTIVIZES MISTER KRAKOFF. A
DISCUSS THAT IS REALLY WHAT
INCENTIVES ARE. NOT JUST GUESS
WHAT SHE GOT THREE DAYS TO DO
THIS AND IF YOU DON'T GUESS
WHAT THE PENALTIES START.
THAT'S NOT. INCENTIVE AND IF
YOU GO BACK TO SKINNER. BACK IN
THE DARK AGES OF BEHAVIORAL
MODIFICATION IN PSYCHOLOGY AND
I WAS A STUDENT OF THAT. THE
BEST LEARNING COMES FROM
INCENTIVES THAT ARE POSITIVE.
ALL WHILE IT'S SLOWER TO CATCH
ON IT LAST A LIFETIME WITH MANY
OF THE SUBJECTS THAT. DOCTOR
SKINNER PUT THROUGH HIS. YOU
KNOW HIS BOX. WITHOUT THIRTIES
AT THAT TIME SO WITHOUT. LET US
GO NOW AND THANK YOU ALL AGAIN
FOR YOUR- CONTRIBUTIONS HERE
TODAY FOR YOUR SERVICE- VERY
VERY. A CHALLENGING ASSIGNMENT
THERE CHECKING ON VERY COMPLEX.
OF THAT YOU KNOW SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE ALL. EXCITED AND UP TO
THE UP TO THE JOB. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO. THOSE WHO.
WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
A REMINDER FOR WITNESSES
WISHING TO PROVIDE COMMENT
BEING VIA PHONE. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN FOUR NINE
SEVEN NINE EIGHT SEVEN YEAH LET
ME REPEAT THAT TOLL FREE NUMBER
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE. SEVEN FOUR NINE
SEVEN NINE EIGHT SEVEN. WILL
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. IN PLEASE APPROACH THE
DIVE. MADAM CHAIR OF MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MARKUP PRIOR I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CHARGE
POINT. YOU HAVE FINAL UP- HERE
BEFORE YOU AN IMPRESSIVE ONE
AND INDEED. I WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT- WE'VE HAD THE PLEASURE.
OF A MEETING WITH THAT DIVISION
ARE HURT AND WE KNOW THAT- SHE
COMES AT THIS WITH A DESIRE TO
ENSURE THAT. A. R. B. AS
SUCCESSFUL IN THE IN THEIR
MISSION- WE ENJOYED THE OTHER
CONVERSATION WE'VE HAD WITH
HER- WE'RE ENCOURAGED BY THE
APPOINTMENT AND YOU'RE
HOPEFULLY YOUR CONFIRMATION. OF
DOCTOR PER CHANNEL WHAT THAT
PARTICULAR A WE THINK IT IS SO
IMPORTANT AND TO ADDRESS THE
COMMENTS. MADE BY CENTER GROVE.
THIS TRANSITION TO A ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE ENVIRONMENT-
WILL NOT BE SUCCESSFUL IF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ARE NOT
UBIQUITOUS AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL. IN THAT AND WHETHER
IT'S THE CENTRAL VALLEY OR IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WITHIN URBAN AREAS FOR F. OR
THE RURAL OR RURAL CALIFORNIA
TO THE NORTH. THESE ARE ISSUES
THAT CONFRONT US AND THAT IF
THEY ARE B. AND IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS. WHO POLICY AND
FUNDING WE NEED TO ADDRESS- WE
ALSO WANT TO ADDRESS OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH- WITH
GETTING CRACK OUT I'VE BEEN AT
THIS FOR THE RECORD AS A-
SENATOR LATER DID I HAVE A-
LONG STANDING RELATIONSHIP.
WITH MR KRAKOW IN THE SOLID
WASTE INDUSTRY- AND THE ONE
THING I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
IMPRESSED BY HIM IS NOT ONLY
THAT HE IS PERSONABLE BUT THAT
HE REALLY GETS INTO THE WEEDS
ON THE ISSUES. HE DOES
LEGITIMATELY LISTEN TO BOTH
SIDES ARE ALL SIDES OF THE
ARGUMENT AND INQUIRES ABOUT
THINGS BEFORE HE MAKES A
DECISION ANY GETS BACK TO YOU
HE LIVES UP TO HIS. COMMITMENT
IN TERMS OF GETTING SOMETHING
DONE. YOU ALSO HAVE A FORMER-
A. R. B. MEMBERS SO YOU. A LOT
OF YOU. YOU KNOW CONTENT. SO IT
WAS IT IS WITH PLACE. AND
CONFIDENCE THAT- WE URGE THIS
COMMITTEE. TO SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION OF THESE A. R. B.
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A NUMBER WITH US HERE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. WELCOME
BY TERM WHERE MEMBERS THANK YOU
I'M TOM KNOX OF VALLEY CLEAN
AIR NOW- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
ALL FOUR NOMINEES. WELL I HATE
TO PLAY FAVORITES BUT- I WANT
TO GIVE SPECIAL ATTENTION TO
OUR SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY REGIONAL
BOARD MEMBER. DR TAKE A WARNER-
WHO IS SHOWN SO MUCH ENTHUSIASM
AND ENERGY- POOR AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS AND SILICON
VALLEY. BUT DURING HER TIME
WITH VALLIER DISTRICT AND WITH
A OR B. SO FAR. BOB THIS IS A
MOBILE SOURCE REDUCTIONS FONG
IS EXCELLENT- SHE'S REALLY
SHOWN A PASSION. FOR THE
POSITION ALREADY- WE WOULD
GREATLY- WELCOME FOR OUR ENERGY.
IN THIS JOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY WHEN
APPROACHING THE DIET SO WE WILL
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE- SEEING
IF THERE'S ANYONE OUT THERE
WANTING TO TEST FIND SUPPORT. I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE. THE N. R. C. NO
MORE WITNESSES- WE WILL MOVE TO
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY BEING VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. ON
MANTA MARGARITA IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE
WILL BEGIN. ALLEN'S ARE. ONLY
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH YOU
SUPPORT PRESS THE ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN AT LONDON'S
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT. WE
CURRENTLY. HAVE ABOUT TWELVE IN
THE QUEUE. THE MOBILE TO LINE
FOR SIX CLEAR GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MCHALE THE OPTIPLEX
PEOPLE TRY INTEREST. SOMETIMES
WORKS WE'RE HE HAD A CONCERN
YOUR CLAIM OF TO BE HEARD. DR
**** MARNER GETTING KRAKOFF IN
LEE AND RANDALL CALIFORNIA AREA
BOARD WE HAVE MET WITH THE
FOREIGN AND FILTERED
BACKGROUNDS AFTER SUPERIOR THEY
WERE VERY GOOD UNDERSTANDING OF
THE ISSUES FACING OUR INDUSTRY
FOR THE REASONS STATED ABOVE IT
IS WITH GREAT PLEASURE THAT WE
RECOMMEND THAT YOU ANA
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE CONFIRM
THE APPOINTMENT OF THE
COMPANIES TO THE CALIFORNIA.
AIR RESOURCES BOARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MAXIM TO LIE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO I HAD. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON- THEN SHARED
MINIMIZE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- ACTUALLY ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAS A MORE FORMAL
STATEMENT ON BEHALF OF
COMMITTEES HE RECALLED BUT- I
DO. NO PROFESSIONALLY AND I'VE
GONE TO KNOW THEM PERSONALLY-
BOTH- DOCTOR BOMBS- AND-
GETTING CRACK OFF. OF KNOWN FOR
MANY YEARS THE DOCTOR BOMBS HAS
BEEN A TREMENDOUS LEADER I HAVE
PUT HIM THAT YOU MY NAME'S THE
MEADOWS AFTER CALL ME REQUESTS
ARE THE ABC ONE SEVEN COUNCIL
AS WE AS THE EIGHT THIRTY EAT
JEFF CALIFORNIA AND RECENT I
CAN SAY STRESSED NOW HON DR BOB.
FOR SO MANY HAS BEEN SUCH A TRY
LEADER WITH SUCH LIMITED TIME
IS A AS THE SIR THAT EATING
CRAP UP I KNOW HIM FROM YEARS
OR FIVE YEARS AND HE IS WORK
OUT WORKING WITH A MOMENTO
JUSTICE THANK YOU GIDEON
EVERYTHING DO WILL YOU BE IT
FROM- LEADER WITHIN VERY FAIR-
I ALSO WANT EXTEND THE SO. TO
LEANDRO RANDOLPH I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORK WITH WITH YOU BY LEANNE
AND YOUR LEADERS AND YOU FOR
REACHING OUT HAVING TO COME-
AND ALSO- CHECK WATER A DOCTOR
WARNER I KNOW MAY QUALITY.
RALLY MANY WHO HAVE LONG TIME
HISTORY WITH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LET ME REMIND THOSE ARE
GOING TO FOR TO. MORE CLEARLY
AND MORE FLOW. FOR ARSENAL FOR
GET OF YOUR- ON THE RECORD WE
MY GO THAT WE WHEN A LITTLE
MORE QUICK AND I DO. SEE A THE
FULL BLANK GIVE ME THE- FOUND
THAT THAT WE TO SEE DOWN SO
JUST FOR THOSE ARE COMING. UP
NEXT PLEASE SOME. STATE YOUR
NAY YOUR OR- AND YOU POST. AND
THEN SLOWLY AND CLEARLY AS
POSSIBLE THANK YOU. MAXIMO
CAROLINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JOHN KENNEDY AND I'M HERE
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE WORLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES TO
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TODAY TO
OFFER SUPPORT ALSO PRETTY
APPOINTMENT TO GET HIM BACK UP
TO A RP BUT WE DON'T REPRESENT
ANY COUNTIES WITHIN SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT'S JURISDICTION WE HAVE
HAD A VERY LONG WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH MR CRACK UP
AND MANY OF HIS FORMER ALSO.
INCLUDES CHAIR OF THE DGSE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL CHAIR
OF THE STATE MINING GEOLOGY
BOARD AND ALSO ON SOLID WASTE
ISSUES WE'VE ALWAYS FOUND THEM
TO BE VERY THOUGHTFUL
DELIBERATE AND FOCUSED ON
PROBLEM SOLVING WE BELIEVE HE
POSSESSES A DEEP UNDERSTANDING
OF THE ISSUES FACING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND WORLD THEY
OFTEN PLAY IN ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. WE
BELIEVE THEY ARE BE WOULD BE
WELL SERVED BY THE BILL'S
APPROACHES THAT MISTER KRAKOFF
ALSO BRINGS TO THE TABLE AND
ARE HAPPY TO SUPPORT OF WOMEN
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CONNECTOME THE LINE FOURTEEN.
PLEASE CALL. THANK YOU MAY VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBER OF COMMITTEE
I'M AT ABS WITH THE BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY DISTRICT IN OF THE
OF THE HONOR TO BE HEARD AT THE
BOARD MEMBER OF THE BAY AREA A
U. M. B. HIS HURT HIS THIS
THING HERSELF BY JUMP INTO A
MOST. INCOME COME BOY COMMITTEE
INCLUDING SOURCE CLIMATE
PROTECTION COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ALSO WITH THE CHAIR
OF OUR COMMUNITY HEALTH EQUITY
AND JUSTICE COMMITTEE FOR
DEDICATION TO THE BAY AREA H.
U. M. B. THE BAY AREA REGION
AND TO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY WILL
MAKE HER A GREAT ADDITION TO
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND
HERE DISTRICT TO STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF HER CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU. MAXIMO TO LINE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE CALL I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON VICE CHAIR BATES AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS SHARON GREEN AND I AM
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT I AM NOT
TRYING TO DANCE RECORDED
GETTING CRACKED UP WHO WE
BELIEVE WILL BRING IMPORTANT
EXPERIENCE AND PERSPECTIVE- TO
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD WE ARE
TO THE COMMITTEE AND THE FULL
SENATE TO APPROVE HIS
CONFIRMATION. AND WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING TO KNOW AND
WORKING WITH THE OTHER NOMINEES
THANK YOU. MAXIMAL TO LINE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT OF ALL FOUR APPOINTEES
BOARD MEMBER BOMBS HAS BROUGHT
INVALUABLE EXPERTISE AND
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC HEALTH TO
THE BOARD FOR MANY YEARS. BOARD
MEMBER KRAKOFF IS A
KNOWLEDGEABLE AND EXPERIENCED
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWYER WHO IS
COMMITTED TO CLEANING UP THE
AIR IN THE SOUTH COAST WHICH
STILL HAS THE SMOGGIEST AIR IN
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND BOARD
MEMBERS PACHINKO WARNER AND HER
ARE ALREADY BRINGING THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE TO THE
BOARD SO WE THINK GOVERNOR
NEWSOM CHOSE WISELY ENERGY TO
CONFIRM ALL OF THEM. MAXIM OF
THE LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GOD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CAMPUS I
WOULD COME HERE BECAUSE I AM
HAVING BECAUSE I BELIEVE SOME
OF THE LARGER PART OF IT WE
APPOINTED DR BOMBS. W. THE BEST
QUALIFIED AND- CERTAINLY MEMBER
IN OF THE TALIBAN. AIR WAS USED
DR BOMBS BURKE TO BE A PER OF
FAIRNESS EDUCATION AND
INTEGRITY. ABOUT TRUSTING HER
WITH LAUNCHING SYSTEM. PUBLIC
HEALTH INVASION FINISH. AND
LOCAL AND STATE THE ONLY. IS
EXPERIENCED KNOWLEDGE AND
ENTHUSIASM HAVE SHOWN THAT THE-
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
COUNTY DEPARTMENT LOOK AT THE
COVERAGE I'M SHOWING ONE OF
JAPAN'S PROGRAMSTHAT BENEFIT.
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
THE PRINTER RECORDS AT I'M LOOK
AT THE THIS COMMENT BUILDING
CALL OF THEIR ACCOUNT. BANDILA
WORK AT THE CHAIR OF THAT SIX
ON SEVEN COUPLE GROUP A FEW
CONFIDENT THAT YOU WILL BE TO.
THE OPENING COLLABORATE.
BETWEEN ADDRESS THEM OTHERS AND
COMMUNITY OF THE UPCOMING
COMMITTEE PROJECT PROGRAM THE
STATE. THANK YOU IT MATTERS ARE.
MADTOM OF THE LINE FORTY THIRD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY EDDIE ON A
BRIGHT LINE IN SUPPORT OF FIRST
MEMBER DIGGING OUT BECAUSE OF
OUR WORK INCREASE BASED ALCOHOL
MONITOR BEGUN TO KNOW HURTS
WORK AND PARTICULAR DATE AREA
AIR QUALITY DISTRICT AND REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION TO
ALL DETAIL. AND CULTURAL DO
SHALL BE AS VOICE FOR BY JUST
FOR THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE
BOARD THANK SECOND WERE ALSO
SUPPORT OF BOB HAVE REALLY
APPRECIATED PERSPECTIVE ON KERR
CRITICAL IN REGARDS TO THE ID
T. ROLE. AND- LOOKING TO YOU
WILL BE A QUALITY AGAIN TWO CAR
THANKS AGAIN FOR YOUR. MAXIMO
LINE TWELVE. WE'VE GOT. BLIND
AIRLINE MADE MEET. BYE BYE
SURVEY TO SENATORS AND ADAM
WITH THE CONSTRUCTION AND OTHER
MATERIAL A SERVICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF GETTING LAPTOPS
CONFIRMATION. DURING MY
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH GETTING
IN ON SUCH COMPLEX ISSUES IS
THE REFORM OF THE SURFACE
MINING RECLAMATION ACT I
LEARNED FIRST HAND THE EFFORT.
HE PLACES IN UNDERSTANDING THE
IMPACTS OF POP ACTION AND PRIME
AND IMPLEMENTABLE SOLUTIONS.
THERE'S THAT WILL SERVE HIM
WELL IN THE CREEK DISCUSS WHICH
COULD OCCUR BEFORE THE- AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. WHICH IS
ALREADY APPLYING BEFORE THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
DISTRICT FOR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND LOOK
FORWARD. TO WORKING WITH
GETTING IN AND THE OTHER BOARD
MEMBERS IN THE FUTURE. MAXIMO
TIMELINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS IS JOHN
MCNAMARA SERIN ARE WORSE WASTE
RECYCLING COMPANY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WORKING IN THE SOUTH
BECAUSE THEY CAN BE DISTRICT WE
WORKED WITH- GETTING IN KRAKOW
FOR SEVERAL YEARS ON. CLEAN
BURNING SOLID WASTE COLLECTION
VEHICLES AND SO WE'RE SUPPORT
SUPPORTING IS THAT APPOINTMENT.
IT IS SENSIBLE ENOUGH AND-
TREATMENT OF THESE KIND OF
ISSUES AND- VERY PROFESSIONAL
AND CAREFUL AND- WE'RE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE A SUPPORT. MAXIM OF THE
LINE THIRTY TO PLEASE GOD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR VICE
MINIMIZED HERE- BATES AND
MEMBERS OF THE RULES COMMITTEE-
CHUCKLED IT ON BEHALF REPUBLIC
SERVICES I WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE CONFIRMATION OF
GETTING CRACK UP. AND HIS
APPOINTMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
RESOURCE BOARD. MR CRACK- THAT
IS DESCRIBED AS A THOUGHTFUL
KNOWLEDGEABLE PROBLEM SOLVER
WE'VE WORKED CLOSELY WITH
GIDEON. ON A WIDE RANGE OF
SOLID WASTE RECYCLING ISSUES.
AND WHEN HE IS NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THAT ISSUE IS NOT AFRAID
TO SAY SO HE ACTIVELY SEEKS
STAKEHOLDER PERSPECTIVE AND
INPUT. HIS POSITION ON THE
GOVERNING BOARD OF THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IS SHOWN THE CAPACITY
TO MANAGE COMPLEX POLICY ISSUES
AND BALANCE OF ACTIVELY THE
IMPACTS ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. WHILE PROVIDING
FAIR CONSIDERATION TO THE
REGULATED COMMUNITY. IT'S NOT
OFTEN THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT FRIEND AND A COLLEAGUE.
IT IS THEREFORE MY GREAT
PLEASURE AND CONFIDENCE THAT WE
OFFER OUR SUPPORT TO THE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CRACK UP. FOR
THE SECOND TIME I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO OFFER A GENERAL SUPPORT
STRUCTURE AND ALL THE OTHER
MEMBERS. OF THE PANEL BEFORE
YOU TODAY THANK YOU. MATT OF
THE LINE FOR. CLEAR. FOR HELLO
THANKS. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES
WE CAN I'M SORRY THIS IS
CATHERINE DODD I'M ANALYZING
FOR AND- THE A NUMBER- WHERE. I
PROFOUND SHIFT A DOCTOR BY BY
ARE MAYES- HE- HAS GOVERNMENT A
COMMITMENT NOT JUST TO RESEARCH
AND- BUDGET MEANINGFUL. HE
WORKS INCREDIBLY WELL INTO
DISCIPLINE THEIR ONLY- HIS
RESEARCH ON THE CHILDREN'S
HEALTH AN AIR POLLUTION STUDY
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY- IS
INVALUABLE AND WE REFERENCED
FREQUENTLY- WE WOULD LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE OURSELVES TOOK- OTHER
REMARKS SUPPORTING OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- BUT JUST.
POINT OUT THAT ALTHOUGH HE'S AN
ACADEMIC HE- DOCTOR BOMBS. IT
GOES BEYOND RESEARCH AND
EFFECTIVELY USE OF SCIENCE TO
EDUCATE STUDENTS AND THE
PUBLIC- DURING THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY FIRES
YOU IMMEDIATELY BEGAN STUDYING
THE HEALTH EFFECTS OF FIRE
SMOKE AND EXAMINE THE
INTERACTIONS WITH CO THE
NINETEEN. AS WE ENTER WHAT'S
BEING CALLED THE WORST FIRE
SEASON OUR STATE'S HISTORY HIS
EXPERTISE WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT AS I SAID HERE THIS
AFTERNOON WE'VE ALREADY HAD AN
ALERT I'M A FIRE WITHIN FOUR.
MILES OF MY HOME YOU ACADEMICS
USERS CLIENTS YOU SHAPE POLICY
AND HE'S WON AND WE PURCHASE
CONFIRMATION AS WE URGE ALL THE
OTHER CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MAXIMO DELIGHT FIFTY
THREE CRITICAL AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A
BILL MAYBE NUMBER. GO TO GET
CON PER OR AND POLICY ADVOCATE.
I'M CALLING FRONT OF GIDEON
CROSS OUT OF THE SCOPE IS THE
GRADUATE STUDENT BASED IN
DISTRICT THIRTY. AND WE BUILD
AND BROWN WEST POWER IN SOUTH
THE LATER DEACON AND JUSTICE
AND ON JUST GONNA CLUB WAS AND
HAD BEEN VERY. OF THE
SUCCESSFUL COLLECTION OF SOUTH
LA AS AN EIGHTY FIFTH SEVEN
COMMUNITY- AND HAS BEEN AN ALLY
YOU CAN BUY A MENTOR JEFF
GROUPS AND TO FROM MY COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE OF THAT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORTED CONFIRMATION TO THE
CALIFORNIA. AIR RESOURCES BOARD
THANK YOU. AT THE TIME NO ONE
ELSE THE QUEUE. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERN. ARE WE'VE HEARD FROM
ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION FOR
WITNESSES WISHING TO PROVIDE
COMMENT BEING PHONE THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AGAIN IS. 844-291-4185 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN FOUR NINE.
SEVEN NINE EIGHT SEVEN LET US
BEGIN WITH A FATHER WITNESSES
THAT MIGHT BE HEARING ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. AND I DO
NOT SEE ANYONE APPROACHING. THE
DIE OFF THEIR FOR WILL IN ROOM
ONE TWO. AND- I SEE NO NO PRO
THE MIKE IN ROOM. WHEN TWELFTH.
SO WITH THAT I BELIEVE. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN THE TO
TEST SO ARM. WE ARE NOT GOING
TO BE FOR NEED TO RE THAT YEAH-
GO TO THE TELEPHONE. WE WILL
NOW GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE AND SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE ARMED WITH WISHING TO
TESTIFY ON THE TELEPHONE
MATAMATA READER. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO UPHOLD
THE PRESS ONES. IN THERE- NOW
AGAIN TO OPPOSE. ONE IN THERE
ON NOW. THE LEAD DO HAVE A IN
THE QUEUE LOCAL LINE FIFTY FOUR
WE'VE AHEAD. WINE FOR FOUR YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THANK CAN
HEAR YOU YOU MAY BE NEW IN YOUR
END. OKAY AND THAT THE TIME NO
AND IN THE. AND I THINK THAT WE
HAVE COMPLETED OUR THE
TESTIMONY FROM BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TODAY-
WILL BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE MEMBERS AND SO. THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND AMONG MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE HAD TO GO TO OTHER
MEETING SO I THINK WE'RE GOOD
ON THAT. AND AS I NOTED EARLIER
VOTES ON THESE FOUR APPOINTEES
WILL BE DEFERRED TO OUR NEXT
COMMITTEE MEETING I'D LIKE TO
AGAIN THANK ON. OUR A NOMINEES
FOR ON THEIR PATIENTS TODAY
IT'S BEEN A LONG LINE BUT WE
THANK YOU ALL FOR VERY VERY
COMPLETE ANSWERS TO OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
AGAIN YOU HAVE A VERY. YOU KNOW
CHALLENGING ALL RULED FOR YOU
AND- WE DO WISH YOU WELL THE
WILL BE BACK ON NEXT WEDNESDAY
I BELIEVE I'LL WIN WILL BE
TAKING A BOAT ON. THE
CONFIRMATION ON NOMINATIONS AND
JOB FULL YEAR FREE TO GO TO THE
REST OF YOUR DAY WHATEVER IS
LEFT HERE. THANKS AGAIN.
KAMPUNG TODAY'S AGENDA. THANK
YOU. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
RULES IS NOW RETURNED. SO I DID
WHAT. ANSWER SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS SO AGAIN THANK
YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR-
PARTICIPATION IN CERTAIN THE-
CORPORATION. AND AGAIN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A VOTE ON OBVIOUSLY-
BOARD MEMBERS NEXT WEDNESDAY.
THANK YOU. NOW WE ARE ADJOURNED.